Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Nimmst du eigentlich über einen sicheren Kanal an dieser Sendung teil?
Natürlich, die Metaebene ist abhörsicher.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 487 vom 18.
März 2024 aus der absolut undurchdringbaren Meta-Ebene, Hochsicherheitszelle.
Hier ist noch jede Konferenz unter den Teilnehmenden geblieben in der Meta-Ebene.
Ja.
Und dem...
Es ist so abhörsicher, die Leute haben sich teilweise untereinander nicht verständigt Sagen wir mal.
Es hat noch niemand gehört, der es nicht hören sollte oder die Das ist ja,
Das soll uns erstmal jemand nachmachen.
Irgendwie bleibt man auch hier unter sich Wir.
Bleiben unter uns und es hört Unter zwei Es hört nur die.
Wieso heißt das eigentlich unter drei?
Ah shit, solche Fragen. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, wieso das ist und ich muss
auch öfter nochmal gucken.
Also ich beziehe mich, falls das jemand nicht weiß, auf diese Abwägung.
Sprach kurz des Journalismus. Unter 1, die Information darf bei direkter Nennung
des Urhebers wörtlich wiedergegeben werden.
Also Angela Merkel sagte, unter zwei, die Information und das Umfeld der Quelle
dürfen zwar wiedergegeben, aber nicht direkt zitiert werden,
wie aus Kreisen der CDU zu erfahren war.
Und unter drei, die Information darf nicht öffentlich verwertet werden.
Aber woher die kommen, weiß ich auch nicht genau.
Was sind wir dann unter vier? Ja.
Wir sind unter 5.
Wir sind unter aller Sau. Ich weiß es nicht. Nee, aber ich...
Aber gibt's da eine Zahl? Ah! Das ist Paragraph 16 der Satzung der Bundespressekonferenz.
Aha. Aber da steht nicht, was...
Aber ich weiß es tatsächlich nicht, was diese Zahl da heißt.
Also woher das der etymologische Ursprung ist.
Aber der wird bestimmt in den Kommentaren uns dann mitgeteilt.
Okay. Eins, zwei, drei gibt es sozusagen und da darf man nichts weiter erzählen.
Wir sind dann also unter fünf, da darf man alles weiter erzählen.
Nee, unter eins darfst du es ja auch. Also unter eins heißt,
du darfst es weiter erzählen. Du darfst genau sagen, von wem.
Ah, das heißt, ihr dürft alles weitererzählen, was ihr heute gehört habt,
aber ihr müsst sagen, dass ihr bei Logbuch Netzpolitik gehört habt. So läuft das.
Unter 1. Unter 2 wäre wie aus gewöhnlich gut unterrichteten Kreisen.
Nee, wir wollen schon Full Credit haben. Also unter 1.
Und heute unter 487.
Das ist nämlich die Ausgabe heute. Habe ich aber schon gesagt. Ich wiederhole mich.
Ja, wir wollen uns aber nicht so viel wiederholen, sondern wollen euch natürlich,
wie es unsere Art ist, hier Informationen liefern.
Und ich würde sagen, wir fangen an mit Feedback, oder?
Gerne.
Okay, fange ich mal an. Also, zum Thema anonyme Bewertungen.
Wir hatten gesprochen über diese Arbeitgeberportal-Geschichte.
Das ist ja zu der Sendung, die ich mit Thomas gemacht habe. Deswegen helfe ich
dir kurz mit dem Kontext.
Und dem anderen.
Wir sind ja unter eins. Siehst du, mit der Anzahl der Personen kann das nichts zu tun.
Ne. Das dachte ich nämlich auch ursprünglich, aber das passt halt irgendwie nicht so richtig.
Das scheint eher sich auf, ja, keine Ahnung, worauf es sich bezieht.
Klärt uns auf. Vielleicht finden wir es auch noch nebenbei raus.
Anyway, Sabrina schreibt uns auf jeden Fall zum Thema anonyme Bewertung.
Ich finde die Idee mit der E-Mail ja ganz nett, aber das geht ja nicht bei jedem Job.
Ich habe zum Beispiel keine E-Mail-Adresse über meinen Arbeitgeber und das dürfte
für Leute an der Kasse, Paketboten und so weiter ja auch gelten.
Und das sind ja gerade die, die in eher prekären Verhältnissen sind und dementsprechend
viel Grund haben, ungünstige Bewertungen zu hinterlassen.
Funktioniert also dann doch nur so ein Semi.
Max fügt dem noch hinzu, außerdem, selbst wenn ich eine dienstliche E-Mail-Adresse
habe, als frisch gegangener Mitarbeiter habe ich diesen Zugriff dann nicht mehr.
Und viel wichtiger, mein Arbeitgeber hat zumindest potenziell vollen Zugriff
auf meine dienstlichen E-Mails herauszufinden.
Wer sich im fraglichen Zeitraum auf diesem Portal angemeldet hat,
ist damit praktisch trivial.
Ja, ich vermute rechtswidrig, aber das kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Also ich fand beide Aspekte wichtig zu diesem Thema.
Also irgendwie, ich habe eine E-Mail-Adresse über den Arbeitgeber und mit der
habe ich mich auch mal auf so einem Arbeitgeberbewertungsportal dann authentifiziert.
Aber klar, bei negativer Bewertung müsste ich davon ausgehen,
dass das theoretisch erkennbar ist, von wem die ist.
Ganz grundsätzlich würde ich vermuten, dass das bei nicht allzu großen arbeitgebenden
Institutionen dann ohnehin auch immer erkennbar ist, weil die vielleicht zeitlich korrelieren.
Aber ja, beide Aspekte, die Max und Sabrina da benennen, sind einfach absolut
zutreffend und deswegen wichtige inhaltliche Ergänzung.
Alright.
Eine weitere wichtige Ergänzung haben wir von Dirk bekommen und zwar hatten
wir gesprochen über die Änderungen,
die Apple auf iOS macht in Reaktion auf das Inkrafttreten des Digital Markets Act.
Insbesondere, dass sie diese Web-Apps für die EU jetzt rausnehmen,
also dass die Progressive Web-Apps, also etwas, was quasi direkt nur als Web-App da läuft und sagen,
das geht deshalb nicht, weil man da jetzt den Browser frei wählen könnte.
So, das habe ich relativ einfach wiedergegeben.
Dazu kommentiert Dirk zum Thema Web-Apps auf iOS.
Apples Argument ist offensichtlich vorgeschoben. Sie haben schon Sandboxing auf App-Ebene.
Dasselbe Sandboxing können und werden sie auch für Third-Party-Web-Browser einsetzen.
Und das können sie natürlich auch für Third-Party-Web-Engine-Web-Apps einsetzen.
Und ich denke auch da klarer Punkt.
Es gab aber weiterhin ohnehin noch, erstaunlich, es scheint ja jetzt hier zum
Krimi zu werden, dass sich diese Regeln da auch ändern werden,
die Apple da jetzt gerade erst bekannt gegeben hat.
Ja, also zunächst einmal zu diesem Sandboxing-Argument. Den Fehler,
den ihr da in der Sendung gemacht habt, der ist vielfältig gemacht worden,
weil es ist oft so dargestellt worden, dass Apple generell keine PWAs,
also Progressive Web Apps mehr ermöglichen würde, dass sie sozusagen komplett
verschwinden. Das ist natürlich Quatsch.
Die verschwinden nicht, weil es sind Web-Apps, die können in jedem Web-Browser
laufen, das ist die Eigenschaft von Web-Apps, die laufen natürlich auch nach wie vor im Browser.
Also es verschwindet in dem Sinne nichts. Was sie angekündigt hatten und was
sie aber mittlerweile auch wieder zurückgenommen haben, interessanterweise, war,
dass sie das Installieren von Web-Apps auf dem Homescreen ausschalten,
die die Möglichkeit geboten haben.
Also man hatte dann sozusagen ein Icon für diese Webseite, mit der das verbunden
ist, die halt eine App repräsentiert, die dann Fullscreen sich öffnet und dann
eben so aussieht, als wäre es eine App,
auch wenn sie tatsächlich nach wie vor eine Web-Anwendung ist,
die im Browser, aber ohne diesen Browser-Chrome läuft.
Und natürlich wäre die App auch sonst nach wie vor genau so weiter gelaufen.
Nur das Ding ist, damit diese App sich wie eine...
Verhalten kann, hatte Apple weitere Dinge hinzu programmiert,
wie zum Beispiel die Integration von System Notifications, also von Web Notifications,
die sich dann wie richtige Notifications anführen und so weiter.
Also es gab sozusagen ein Integrationspaket, was eben diese Web Apps noch in
gewisser Hinsicht ein wenig promotet hat und sozusagen noch mehr wie Apps hat aussehen lassen.
Das ist allerdings etwas, was sie halt zu ihrem Webkit-System dazugebaut haben.
Das hat mit Sandboxing und Sicherheit an der Stelle überhaupt nichts zu tun,
sondern es geht sozusagen darum,
dass wenn sie all diesen sonstigen Komfort auch mit anderen Browser-Engines
noch bereitstellen sollten, die von Third-Party sind, müssten sie für die wiederum
nochmal ein eigenes Framework aufmachen,
damit die sich da reinklinken können, um für Web-Apps, die unter ihrer Engine laufen,
denselben Komfort zu haben. Und da hat Apple gesagt, das machen wir nicht.
Jetzt gab es einige neue Regelungen, also einige Abschwächungen oder andere
Teiländerungen in dieser ganzen Geschichte, die ich vorgetragen hatte.
Und eine davon ist, dass es jetzt diese Progressive Web Apps auf dem Homescreen
doch geben soll, aber dann eben auch nur mit WebKit.
Und das ist, wie manch andere Sachen, die sie jetzt auch noch verkündet haben,
vermutlich, das weiß man nicht so ganz genau, Ergebnis eines Dialogs,
der hinter den Kulissen mit der EU läuft.
Anders kann ich mir das ehrlich gesagt nicht erklären, weil es gibt jetzt in
dem Sinne noch keine rechtlichen Auseinandersetzungen, also zumindest keine,
die ich kenne und ich habe so
den Eindruck, es ist jetzt halt einfach mal Feedback eingesammelt worden,
sowohl Feedback von Developern als auch Feedback von der EU-Kommission,
von den zuständigen Arbeitsgruppen, keine Ahnung, das weiß man nicht,
weil sie dann eben gesagt haben,
nee, wir machen jetzt Homescreen doch wieder, aber das geht dann halt nur mit ihrer Engine.
Was ja eigentlich entgegen dieser Idee der Bevorzugung einer Browser-Engine ist.
Aber die ist halt jetzt dann wieder doch noch ein bisschen bevorzugt,
aber offensichtlich auf eine Art und Weise, wo die EU gesagt hat,
das ist uns egal, weil die können ja dann trotzdem noch in dem anderen Browser auch laufen.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Ja, habe ich falsch wiedergegeben?
Das haben ganz viele missverstanden.
Oder falsch verstanden. Dann danke Dirk für die Korrektur und danke dir Tim
für die noch sinnvollere Einordnung.
Dann haben wir über das Thema Content Warnings gesprochen und in dem Kontext
habe ich zumindest meinen vorsichtigen Zweifel ausgedrückt,
dass wenn man jetzt ein Wort liest, dass man dann nicht daran denkt.
Ja und das hat aber René gerade gerückt, dass es nur daran denken nicht unbedingt bedeutet,
dass man auch eine potenzielle Retraumatisierung erfährt und vielleicht möchtest
du diesen längeren Kommentar einmal vorlesen.
Also René schreibt zum Thema Content Warnings.
Es wird leider etwas länger, aber vielleicht hilft es dem einen oder anderen
das Ganze besser zu verstehen. Ich bin selbst Trauma-Überlebender.
An alle möglichen Inhalte Content Warnings dran zu klatschen,
halte ich für absolut falsch und sogar gefährlich.
Aber es gibt durchaus einen sinnvollen Use Case, der einem vielleicht nicht
klar ist, wenn man nicht selbst betroffen ist oder sich sehr gut mit dem Thema
auskennt. Um beim Beispiel von Linus zu bleiben.
Es macht einen himmelweiten Unterschied, ob ich das Wort Vergewaltigung lese
oder ob ich mit konkreten Einzelheiten,
Details, Beschreibungen einer Vergewaltigung konfrontiert bin.
Selbst wenn die Details für andere vielleicht unscheinbar sind.
Ersteres stecken viele mit Traumafolgestörungen noch gut weg.
Vielleicht kommen da auch schon gewisse Assoziationen auf, aber man kann es
noch unter Kontrolle halten.
Sobald es mehr ins Detail geht, wird es aber schwierig. Denn wenn das traumatisierte
Gehirn in der Schilderung genügend Ähnlichkeit zu selbst erlebten Dingen sieht,
drohen Dissoziationen, eine Art Schutzmechanismus des Körpers und im schlimmsten Fall Flashbacks.
Diese Ähnlichkeiten können marginal klein sein und trotzdem schon ausreichen.
Ein Flashback ist nicht so wie in Filmen gerne dargestellt ein ablaufender Film
vorm inneren Auge, etwas an das man sich zurückerinnert.
Es fühlt sich in diesem Moment komplett real an. Man fühlt und verhält sich
so, als wäre man wieder in der traumatisierenden Situation.
Das Lesen eines bestimmten Details kann mich also dazu bringen,
die schlimmsten Momente meines Lebens erneut erleben zu müssen.
Flashbacks wirken in der Regel auch noch eine Zeit lang nach.
Im Worst Case kann es bei mir dazu führen, dass ich mehrere Nächte kaum schlafe,
nicht mehr aus dem Haus komme und mich für mindestens ein oder zwei Tage krank melden muss.
Hier hilft natürlich eine Traumatherapie besser als jede Content Warning,
aber Plätze für Traumatherapien sind leider noch viel seltener als normale Therapieplätze.
Und gerade komplexe Traumata aus der Kindheit arbeitet man nicht mal eben so
auf, da reden wir häufig über viele Jahre dauernde Behandlung.
Bei Themen, die sehr häufig mit tatsächlichen Traumafolgestörungen assoziiert
sind, Vergewaltigung ist da ein sehr gutes Beispiel,
halte ich es daher für extrem sinnvoll die Inhalte zu markieren,
sodass jede selbst die Wahl hat, ob sie damit gerade konfrontiert werden möchte
oder eben nicht. Lichtkontrolle ist dabei ein gutes Stichwort.
Traumaüberlebende haben häufig völligen Kontrollverlust erlebt und erleben ihn
in solchen Situationen wieder im Kleinen.
Wie jede im Grundsatz gute Idee gibt es auch hier wieder Menschen,
die diese eigentlich gute Idee im blinden Aktionismus ad absurdum führen.
Politische Inhalte oder beispielsweise Essen hinter Content Warnings verstecken
zu wollen ist eine echt schlechte kontraproduktive Idee, weil meine Ausführungen
jetzt schon so lang sind, belasse ich es mal dabei.
Ja, also finde ich einen wichtigen Aspekt.
Ich glaube, das kann man einfach mal so stehen lassen.
Das kann man so stehen lassen und ich denke, das ist halt auch wirklich der
entscheidende Unterschied.
Also meine Berichte, reale Schilderungen von schwierigen Situationen oder von
Situationen, die für andere Leute schwierig sind, natürlich was anderes als
eine generelle Diskussion.
Also wichtig ist aber natürlich, René bezieht sich hier sehr konkret eben auch
auf Dinge, die traumatisierend sind.
Also da gibt es schon einige Dinge, die vielleicht nicht so traumatisierend sind.
Dann gibt es noch, hatten wir des Weiteren darüber gesprochen,
dass es im Fediverse die spezifische Diskussion gibt, ob man denn nun mit Netzen
wie Threads oder Blue Sky föderieren,
also mit anderen Worten die eigenen Inhalte dieser Netzwerke und auch die Inhalte
dieser Netzwerke den eigenen Nutzerinnen zugänglich machen.
Machen möchte oder ob man die komplett ausschließt und ja, also das Defediverse pflegt.
Und dazu kommentierte Oliver Müller zum Thema Föderation mit anderen Netzen
wie Threads und BlueSky.
Linus hat das Problem nicht verstanden.
Die Sorge ist nicht, dass Meta und BlueSky an die Daten kommen,
sondern dass deren unmoderierter Content ins Fediverse schwappt.
Keins der großen Unternehmen bekommt das mit der Moderation hin.
Ich möchte diesen Müll nicht im Fediverse.
Tja, das ist natürlich,
ja, also das ist klar, dass das so ein bisschen die Angst zu sein scheint,
dass man sich eben mit den großen Netzwerken, die angeblich die Content-Moderation
nicht hinbekommen, dann automatisch viele Kommentierende reinholt,
die sonst vielleicht so nicht auftauchen würden.
Da bin ich mir jetzt aber nicht so sicher, ob das quasi jetzt nur auf die großen
Plattformen so beschränkt ist.
Ich meine, das kann ja natürlich im Fediverse auch sonst passieren.
So und hier gibt es ja so eine spezifische Angst vor Threads oder anderen Netzwerken,
die sich in irgendeiner Form an das Fediverse noch ranklinken könnten.
Und da muss man aber sagen, ich meine, das Moderationsproblem hast du natürlich
im Fediverse genauso. so.
Und das wird derzeit eigentlich nur dadurch gelöst, dass man sagt,
naja, wenn es sozusagen ein Problem gibt, dann kann ich das auf Server-Ebene abschalten.
Es gibt dann so einen Rogue-Server, wo nicht ordentlich moderiert wird und dann
wird das halt einfach komplett rausgenommen.
Davon ausgehend, dass das sich in irgendeiner Form lokal begrenzen lässt.
Und das funktioniert natürlich bei Threads so nicht mehr, weil du wirst sehr
viel Quality-Content haben, Aber eben auch sehr viel negativen Content,
aber nichts garantiert dir, dass das nicht auf mastodon.social genauso ist.
So, was heute eh schon die allergrößte Instanz in diesem Fediverse ist und was willst du dann machen?
Willst du dann irgendwie mastodon.social abkneifen, dann wird natürlich diese
Moderationsdiskussion dort ganz genauso geführt werden und Regeln erstellt werden.
Also es ist ein generelles ungelöstes Problem in Social Media und ich glaube
nicht, dass man das jetzt so ohne weiteres, dass man so mit dem Finger auf einzelne
Systeme zeigen kann und sagen, ihr seid jetzt generell ein Problem.
Außer vielleicht Schutz.Social.
Also kämen mir zwei Gedanken zu. Also wenn jetzt, also truth.social wäre sowas,
wo ich auch denken würde, das könnte man vielleicht mal deföderieren.
Gleichzeitig würde ich mir aber auch denken, was mache ich denn,
beispielsweise, wenn auf meiner Instanz sich eine Journalistin befindet,
die für ihre Recherchen spezifisch sich diese Inhalte anschauen möchte.
Also, kann ich dann als Betreiberin einer Instanz sagen, nee,
also das darfst du nicht.
Ja klar, kann ich, ist ja alles, ich weiß, darf ich, kann ich,
bitte nicht nochmal erklären.
Also kann ich, ja, aber ist das jetzt eine moralische Position, das zu tun?
Dass ich also direkt eine ganze Instanz blocke. Also nach meinem Verständnis,
ich kann das ja nur von anderen Leuten mir anhören, die sowas tun,
gibt es da irgendwie ein Spam-Problem?
Ja, also da gibt es potenziell irgendwie Instanzen, die offene Registrierung
oder sowas haben und dann spammen die andere voll.
Ich persönlich, mir ist das noch nicht passiert, also ich habe keinen Spam bekommen. kommen?
Ich denke, wir haben vor allem im Fediverse derzeit einfach noch kein Spam-Problem,
weil es einfach noch nicht groß genug ist.
Nee, also das wird ja schon berichtet. Also wenn ich so mit,
Betreiberinnen spreche, die sagen dann schon, dass sie teilweise eben Server
sperren müssen oder es dann irgendwelche Spam-Wellen gibt, weil wieder irgendwo,
und dann ist man da ein paar Tage am Klicken und muss irgendwann ein paar Server deföderieren oder so.
Das, also Also wird mir schon berichtet.
Ich persönlich kann das nicht beurteilen.
Vielleicht habe ich lange Zeit davon profitiert, dass andere Menschen das getan haben.
Gleichzeitig weiß ich aber, also ich finde diese Entscheidung, da jetzt quasi Inhalte,
ganze riesige Mengen an Inhalten nicht zugänglich zu machen,
per se schon eine sehr folgenschwere Frage.
Also, zumal es jetzt konkret bei Threads, und darum geht es ja hier eigentlich
primär, weil das ist ja nur die einzige Plattform, die gesagt hat,
sie will sich mal aktiv in das Fediverse mit einklinken, hast du natürlich das Problem,
dass, klar ist da eine Menge Unsinn unterwegs, gar keine Frage.
Genau, weil auch eine ganze, also die relative Zahl ist wahrscheinlich relativ
gering, aber die absolute Zahl ist dann eben sehr hoch.
Genau und ich meine, das ist nun mal der Netzwerkeffekt. Ich meine,
ich wäre jetzt nicht überrascht, wenn es nicht sogar schon so weit ist.
Ich kenne jetzt die aktuellen Zahlen gar nicht, aber bei Twitter gehen halt
die Nutzerzahlen weiterhin zurück und bei Threads gehen sie sicherlich nicht
nennenswert zurück, wenn sie mal.
Also sie ging glaube ich kurz zurück, nachdem der erste Hype durch war.
Aber grundsätzlich wird das kein kleines Netzwerk bleiben und kann halt sehr
gut sein, dass das eben eins der Systeme ist, wo das Interesse dann hinschwappt.
Und was machst du dann, um daran teilzunehmen, wenn du teilnehmen möchtest?
Dann bist du da halt unterwegs.
Also ich habe mir ja schon von vielen Leuten gewollt oder ungewollt das Fediverse erklären lassen.
Aber ganz grundsätzlich habe ich nicht das Verständnis, dass meine Instanz irgendeinen
Schaden nimmt, wenn sie jetzt eine andere nicht deföderiert.
Also angenommen, truth.social, um jetzt mal bei einer sicherlich nicht mit besonderen
Inhalten gesegneten Instanz,
ja, angenommen, ich bin jetzt auf einer Mastodon-Instanz und da gibt es woanders
truth.social im Fediverse, passiert doch gar nichts.
Nämlich passiert ja erst dann was auf meiner Instanz, wenn sich jetzt eine meiner
Nutzerinnen entscheidet, einer Truth.Social Nutzerin zu folgen.
Dann ist die Konsequenz, dass das bei mir in der Federated Timeline als Nutzer erscheint.
Es geht ja nicht nur um die Federated Timeline, sondern es geht ja auch darum,
wer dir sozusagen, wer auf dich reagiert.
Dann können ja dann auch Leute von Truth Social dir folgen und dann dich halt mit Replies zu ballern.
Genau, und dann wäre es in jedem anderen sozialen Netzwerk, wäre es dann so,
dass ich diese Personen blocken müsste, was ich problemlos kann.
Also wäre jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Anspruch, den ich an die Betreiberin der
Instanz erheben würde, zu sagen, schützt mich vor Followern von Truth.Social.
Naja, wenn es dann halt so endemisch wird, dass man irgendwie sagt,
99% aller Beschwerden kommen nur von diesem einen Server, dann ist das sicherlich
zu so einem Punkt eskaliert, wo man über sowas auch nachdenken könnte.
Aber grundsätzlich stellt sich eher die Frage, welche Moderationsmöglichkeiten wird es denn geben?
Also es gab ja bei Twitter, bevor Elon Musk das übernommen hat,
durchaus einige Maßnahmen,
die ich jetzt im Einzelnen gar nicht mehr runterbeten kann, aber es gab ja so
verschiedene Konstellationen, wo dann sozusagen Replies gar nicht auftauchen,
wenn die nicht so einen bestimmten Status haben etc.
Und das sind natürlich alles so Dinge, die sich letzten Endes im Finiverse auch
dann schrittweise etablieren müssen, weil wir werden dieses Problem dort haben.
Also Threads hin, Threads her.
Umso mehr Interesse das Netzwerk anzieht, umso mehr wird es solche Moderationsprobleme
geben und dann stellen sich genau dieselben Fragen, egal ob man jetzt einen
anderen Server blockt oder nicht.
Also diese Methoden müssen ohnehin geschaffen werden und das System muss halt
da auch mithalten mit dem, was andere Netze dort anzubieten haben.
Also es wird spannend werden zu sehen, aber Social Media ist nicht einfach.
Nee, nee, das ist es nicht. Aber was auch immer Twitter gemacht hat,
hatte ich den Eindruck, dass es
bis zu dieser Übernahme durch Elon Musk ausreichend gut funktioniert hat.
Also wir haben ja die, also ausreichend gut heißt nicht gut,
aber ausreichend, um zumindest die Plattform am Leben zu halten und die Fälle
der Belästigung für einen ausreichend großen Anteil der Nutzerinnen auf einem
ausreichend niedrigen Niveau zu halten.
So, also das heißt nicht, dass es kein Problem gab, aber es hat nicht die Plattform
als solche gefährdet Elon Musk hat das relativ schnell sehr stark zum Kippen gebracht ähm.
Also es war offenbar ein Problem, was mal jemand halbwegs im Griff hatte.
Was nicht, nur damit das jetzt nicht wieder die Leute falsch verstehen,
was nicht heißen soll, dass das Problem gelöst war, wie kein Problem,
was da ist, wo es mehr als einen Menschen gibt, war das vollständig gelöst.
Und ich will auch nicht in Abrede stellen, dass es schwere Fälle von Beleidigung
und Belästigung und Verbal Abuse und ganz schrecklichen Inhalten da gibt.
Aber der größere Teil der Nutzerinnen hat das Ausmaß offenbar für ausreichend
gering gehalten, um zumindest noch die Plattform weiterzunutzen.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Aussage, die ich so vorsichtig treffen kann.
Ganz so. Danke.
Womit wir beim nächsten Thema wären. Danke Markus Beckedahl. Erstes Thema.
Meine Güte, der Markus, erstes Thema bei uns in der Sendung.
Ja, ist eigentlich auch nur eine kleine Meldung, könnte man sagen.
Vielleicht auch nicht. Also Markus Beckedahl, der ja glaube ich in der Öffentlichkeit
sehr mit seinem Projekt Netzpolitik.org verbunden ist, was er vor gut 20 Jahren gegründet hat.
Verlässt jetzt das Schiff und wendet sich anderen Dingen zu und da fällt einem
erstmal auf dass das ja schon 20 Jahre sind,
21 war 21 wann ist das online gegangen?
Die Webseite wurde 2002 von Markus Beckedahl als Blog gegründet Okay.
Also über 20.
Jahre Ich wäre jetzt fast sicher gewesen, dass es 2004 war, weil ich mal nach der ähm,
nach einem Redesign Aufkleber gemacht hatte.
Genau, bei dem Redesign, einem der Redesigns, die ich mal gemacht hatte für
Netzpolitik.org stand oben drauf seit 2002 offensichtlich und mein Gehirn hat
mir gesagt, es wäre seit 2004 gewesen.
Ja, aber genau, seit 2002, also 21, 22 Jahre.
Ich hatte auch 2004 im Kopf, weil ich hatte auch, also ich habe tatsächlich
mal mit ihm Einen der aller aller aller ersten Chaos Radio Express Folgen gemacht.
Damals noch als es so hieß.
Heute ja nur noch CRE. Und wo ich halt noch überhaupt gar nicht wusste,
was dieses Format irgendwann mal sein würde.
Und CRE 007 ist sozusagen mit ihm.
Da ist er gerade, ich glaube aus Tunesien oder so zurückgekommen. Bei diesem WSIS,
irgendein internationales Meeting und da haben wir uns darüber unterhalten und
da kam dann auch das erste Mal so Notznetzpolitik.org als Projekt zur Sprache.
Offenbar schon 2005 einen ersten Freedom Blog Award bekommen von Reporter ohne
Grenzen, also ja, dann wird das schon stimmen mit dem 2002.
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist das ein interessanter Flashback auch,
weil gerade so diese Zeit 2004, 2005, 2006 ist bei mir stark in Erinnerung.
Klar, weil das so auch ein bisschen der Start der Meta-Ebene war,
aber vor allem, weil es ja auch die Zeit war, in der ...
Die Publikation im Internet auf einmal so ein individuelles Ding wurde.
Vorher in den ersten zehn Jahren des Webs, so ab 94 ungefähr, war ja so Publikation.
Erstmal kamen ja die ganzen Firmen mit so, ja, wir haben jetzt auch eine Internetpräsenz
und unsere Visitenkarte im Web und so weiter, wo dann irgendwelche bekloppten
Werbeagenturen Werbeagenturen für völlig überdrehte Millionenbeträge beauftragt wurden,
irgendwie fünf HTML-Seiten mit Flash-Content zu erzeugen, der dann irgendwie
rumgehüpft hat, wenn man drauf ging.
Das waren gute Zahlen für die Werbeagenturen.
Das war also wirklich eine Wichserei, das war wirklich einfach furchtbar und
ja okay, für die Werbeagenturen war das natürlich geil,
das ist halt immer so bei diesen Hypes, wenn irgendwas neu ist,
keiner weiß, was es ist, aber du musst halt irgendwie dabei sein,
sonst kannst du dich vor deinen Business-Kollegen nicht mehr ordentlich zeigen,
dann wird halt höllisch viel Geld auf einmal klar gemacht, um irgendwie die Zukunft zu machen.
Und was haben wir hier schon für Hypes, jetzt ist es halt gerade AI oder wenn
du jetzt nicht irgendwie AI auf deine Kleidung draufstempelst,
dann brauchst du dich auf der nächsten Businessmesse gar nicht mehr zeigen und so weiter.
Und naja, die Zeit war dann halt irgendwann reif, dass genug Werkzeuge da waren,
dass dieses Publizieren nicht mehr so schwierig war und dann kamen halt solche
Systeme auf wie Textpattern und dann später auch WordPress,
die halt, hier ist dieses andere Blogging-System noch, komme ich jetzt gerade
nicht drauf, also man konnte auf einmal bloggen.
So, man konnte selber einfach irgendwie was reinschreiben in das Internet und
dann erschien das irgendwie.
Und 2004, 5, 6, das waren so…,
Der Aufbruch für Text, also 2004 ging so dieser totale Blog-Hype los,
war ja dann auch bald die Geburtsstunde der Republika, das kam ja dann auch mit in diese Zeit rein.
Nein, 2005 war dann so dieses, oh wow, ja also erstmal so diese Begeisterung,
oh bloggen, was, man kann selber was reinschreiben und dann schreibe ich das
in die Webseite und dann steht das da, so unglaublich.
So, jetzt ist jeder, seine eigene Zeitung, werden Zeitungen überleben, ja, sofort so,
was, ganze Industrien werden jetzt untergehen, weil jemand bloggt.
So, Markus Beckedahl schreibt jetzt selber was über Netzpolitik.org und muss
nicht bei der Zeit fragen, dass das irgendwie im Internet veröffentlicht wird.
Und ein Jahr später hattest du das dann mit Podcast oh man, was man kann Ton
aufnehmen und im Internet einfach so veröffentlichen ohne beim Radio zu sein.
Was geht denn jetzt ab, wird das Radio überleben,
so, ganze Industrien werden untergehen weil jetzt Leute irgendwie in ihrem Mikrofon
ins Internet sprechen sind.
Sie doch auch oder nicht?
Es hat aber wirklich jetzt noch sehr lange gedauert und 2006,
weißt du was aus 2006 rauskam?
Äh, äh, YouTube. Oh.
Und dann ging das mit Videos los.
Ja, also das war ja, also insgesamt.
Was Videos? Jeder kann Video, wird das Fernsehen überleben irgendwie.
Ja, Tim, du überlebst gerade Web 2.0, ne?
Genau, aber das war im Prinzip.
Aber es gab ja noch eine, wie ich finde, wichtige andere oder weitere,
also was das Blog ausgemacht hat, Etwa nicht nur, dass es ein Content-Management-System
ist, dass man sich plötzlich bei seiner Webseite einloggen und die Inhalte selber verändern kann,
sondern auch diese Funktionalität der Trackbacks.
Etwas, was dann auch irgendwann dem Spam zum Opfer gefallen ist,
habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck.
Aber was es Blogs ermöglichte, sich automatisch miteinander bekannt zu machen
oder zu verlinken, also funktioniert so.
So, du, es gibt jetzt so ein Blogartikel, sagen wir, bei Netzpolitik.org und
jetzt geht ein weiteres Blog, sagen wir mal Spreeblick, gab es ja damals zum Beispiel,
da gibt es vielleicht immer noch, aber und schreibt einen,
Artikel, der darauf Bezug nimmt und dann wird dieser Link und verlinkt dabei
Netzpolitik.org, dann sagt der Spreeblick-Server dem Netzpolitik.org-Server Bescheid, übrigens,
hier hat jemand gerade was was dazu geschrieben und auf dich verlinkt.
Und wir geben dir jetzt mal so einen kleinen Snippet davon.
Packen das da drunter und das kannst du dann, wenn du möchtest,
als Kommentar annehmen.
So, das machte aber immerhin möglich, dass diese Blogosphäre entstand,
wo dann gegenseitig aufeinander Bezug genommen wurde.
Und ich glaube, bis Netzpolitik.org irgendwann hart in die Kommentare eingegriffen hat,
war wahrscheinlich jede Logbuch-Netzpolitik-Folge ein Trackback unter vielen
Netzpolitik.org-Artikeln.
Weil sich ja nach wie vor unsere Inhalte naturgemäß sehr stark auch mit den
Inhalten von Netzpolitik.org.
Johnny Häusler hatte damals dann glaube ich noch so eine Sendung im Radio Trackback
oder war das ein Podcast?
Das war schon noch so ein ausschlaggebender Aspekt des Blogs,
aber wir müssen vielleicht gar nicht so viel über Blogs reden.
Nee, aber du machst einen guten Punkt, weil das muss man sich mal klar machen,
dass das also wirklich eine wichtige Aufbruchszeit war.
Auch die Hashtags wurden im Prinzip in der Blogosphäre damals noch unter dem
Namen Technorati-Tags geboren.
Also auch das war sozusagen das erste Tagging, diese erste Idee von Content
unter einem Stichwort zusammenzufassen. Da kommt sozusagen das Tag her.
Man hat dann seine Blogartikel getaggt und Technorati hat dann alle Blogs abgesucht
und dann sozusagen konntest du auf Technorati nach einem Hashtag suchen und
dann fandest du eben Blogartikel zu diesem Thema.
Die waren aber nicht notwendigerweise, also Tags waren nicht notwendigerweise
mit einem Hash davor. vor.
Ne, also Technorati-Tags, Hash hat sich dann durchgesetzt auf Twitter. Ja.
Das kam noch dann, dann wurden es die Hash-Tags, weil sie halt noch ein Hash davor hatten.
Genau, so, aber die Tags an sich sind mit Technorati geboren worden,
eine Webseite, die dann halt auch irgendwann dem Spam zum Opfer gefallen ist.
Das waren alles super Ideen, aber im Prinzip so die die,
Geburtsstunde dieses Individual- Und genau da ist dann halt Markus reingegangen
mit Netzpolitik.org und hat eigentlich das erste wirklich nennenswerte netzpolitische,
ähm,
Wie soll man denn das nennen? Also Pamphlet, hatte ich fast gesagt.
Also die erste wirkliche Quelle sozusagen geschaffen für so netzpolitischen Content.
Er hat sogar den Begriff geprägt. Also den Begriff gab es jetzt nicht notwendigerweise.
Also vielleicht hat den jemand anderes vorher verwendet, aber er hat ihn etabliert.
Ja, er hätte ja auch zum Beispiel Digitalpolitik nehmen können.
Übrigens gehört ihm offenbar die Domain digitalpolitik.de, wo er jetzt bloggt.
Tja.
Auf eigene Beine ging und ich war, wenn ich das recht erinnere,
der erste quasi angestellte Autor.
Davor gab es viele Gastschreiber,
Jörg-Olaf Schäfers und auch eigentlich viele Leute aus dieser ganzen Netzpolitik-Bubble
und mit dieser Herauslösung,
ich glaube,
mein Arbeitsvertrag war sogar noch mit New Thinking.
Aber da ging das dann langsam los, dass Netzpolitik da rausgelöst wurde.
Davor war ich Praktikant. Ich bin also als Praktikant dann in eine sehr prekär
bezahlte Stelle, aber immerhin eine bezahlte Stelle gewechselt und dann...
Hat sich das über die Jahre eben immer weiterentwickelt. Ich denke nennenswert
vor allem, dass dann 2015 die Landesverratsaffäre war.
Das hat glaube ich nochmal sehr stark zur Wahrnehmung von Netzpolitik Erk dann
nochmal beigetragen und nochmal sehr viel mehr das Ding auf stabile Beine gestellt,
auch was das Spendenaufkommen anging.
Und inzwischen, ich lese immer die Finanzberichte und so, aber wenn wir jetzt mal kurz schauen,
haben die ungefähr eine Million an quasi Spendenaufkommen im Jahr,
mit der sie 2023 20 Mitarbeiter finanziert haben.
Also da ist nochmal einiges passiert, nachdem ich da wieder weggegangen bin.
Genau. Und ja, inzwischen natürlich was ganz anderes als das Blog,
was Markus da mal selber,
mehr oder weniger selber betrieben hat und dann als es groß genug war,
Leute von sich aus eben auch gerne dort geschult haben.
Also klar, war auf jeden Fall eines der größten, wenn nicht das größte Blog
der deutschen Blogosphäre.
Natürlich habe ich mich da gefreut, schreiben zu dürfen.
Bis wann hast du da geschrieben?
Ich würde schätzen 2011, Ende 2011.
Bis ich abgeworben habe.
Habe. Also das war ja so, ich bin gegangen,
ist jetzt glaube ich auch kein Geheimnis, weil ich ein bisschen mehr Einkommen
dann doch brauchte, also ich habe meine monatlichen Kosten dadurch nicht decken können,
habe dann eben in die IT Security gewechselt, wo ich einen Job bekommen habe, der meine monatlichen,
Aufwände ganz gut decken konnte und eher wirklich durch, also completely unrelated
Related kam das ungefähr zusammen, dass ich meinen Job gewechselt habe und Logbuch
Netzpolitik angefangen habe.
Was aber damit zu tun hatte, dass du, also es waren zwei unabhängige Prozesse.
Die hatten jetzt nichts miteinander zu tun. Die sind einfach nur koinzidiert.
Dann habe ich ja auch noch eine Zeit lang, also ich glaube, wenn das mir jetzt
nicht jemand heimlich weggenommen hat, habe ich immer noch Schreibrechte bei
Netzpolitik.org. Also ich könnte jederzeit….
Aufgestellt hat, aber ich kann sicherlich nicht andere Sachen editieren und löschen.
Es sei denn, die haben immer noch meine Backdoor in dem ... ... ...
...
... ...
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Ich glaube nicht, dass es jemanden gibt,
die die Netzpolitik in in Deutschland in ihrer Berichterstattung,
aber auch in ihrer Kampagnenfreudigkeit so stark geprägt hat wie Markus Beckedahl.
Und das hat sich ja auch gerade mit dem von dir schon erwähnten Landesverratsskandal gezeigt.
Ich kann mich noch erinnern, also als das rauskam, es hat nicht lang gedauert,
war das nicht so in wenigen Stunden, war dann auf einmal so eine Demonstration
auf der Straße von mehreren hundert Leuten.
Also ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie lang der Vorlauf, vielleicht war es
auch nur ein Tag oder so. Aber es war, das kam raus und es gab spontan große
Demonstrationen, so im Regierungsviertel.
Und also der Vorlauf war glaube ich nicht mehr als ein Tag oder so oder zwei vielleicht.
Immer auf jeden Fall schnell.
Genau. Und das hat dann schon gezeigt und glaube ich aber auch dem Establishment
gezeigt, dass so dieses kleine Block nicht mal einfach so totzuschießen ist,
sondern sehr viel mehr Relevanz hat.
Das ist ja noch so eine Zeit, wo einfach dieses ganze Netzgewese nicht so richtig ernst genommen wurde.
Und auch diese Zusammenhänge, also das war, sie haben Pläne des Bundesverfassungsschutzes,
des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz für den Aufbau einer Einheit zur Überwachung
des Internets veröffentlicht.
Und die waren natürlich, das war natürlich einfach ein Leak aus dieser Behörde,
ja, und die wurden die Strafanzeige die kam von Hans-Georg Maaßen dem Hans-Georg Maaßen-Mann der Typ,
ja und dann wurde sie also das hatten sie veröffentlicht im Frühjahr 2015,
hat auch keine Sau interessiert dann haben sie die im Mai 2015 hat dann der
damalige Generalbundesanwalt Harald Range ein Ermittlungsverfahren eröffnet,
Und dann, glaube ich, hat das irgendwie bis Juli oder August gedauert,
bis sie das auch erfahren haben. Ne.
Genau, ich sehe, achso, und dann wurde es aber auch relativ schnell eingestellt
und ich glaube, dass der Range dann dafür auch noch irgendwie größeren Ärger
bekommen hat. Naja, wie dem auch sei, wahnsinnige Geschichte.
Mein bescheidener Beitrag damals war Landesverrat.org, wo ich dann diese Inhalte
bereitgestellt habe, weil Netzpolitik.org, die ja auch, genau,
die mussten die ja dann offline nehmen.
Und dann gab es eben einige, die sich getraut haben, diese Inhalte zu spiegeln.
Und da gab es noch eine starke Kritik, die Tagesschau hatte sich das nicht getraut. Ja, weil...
Dass Markus da langsam gehen würde, hat sich ja über die Zeit nachverfolgen lassen.
Er hat ja schon vor längerer Zeit die Chefredaktion abgegeben und das dann an
die Doppelspitze Anna Biselli und Daniel Leisegang übergeben.
Und ja, dass jetzt offenbar nach längerer Zeit dann eine vollständige Aufgabe
auch seiner Herausgeberschaft ist.
Und womit auch, also er hat dann nicht mehr viel geschrieben,
aber dann so eine Kolumne gehabt und so und in seiner Danke-Netzpolitik.org,
in seinem letzten Beitrag sagt er sogar, dass er jetzt auch quasi den Schreibzugriff,
den standardmäßigen Schreibzugriff abgibt.
Ja, und dann hat er eben unter digitalpolitik.org bloggt er jetzt eben weiter.
Wobei man vielleicht auch sagen muss, das kann man schon sagen,
Entschuldigung, digitalpolitik.de, jetzt habe ich fast den Fehler,
wozu man vielleicht auch sagen muss, Markus war schon eigentlich immer Blogger.
Der hat eher einen Freund des schnellen Raushauens, des kurzen Kommentars.
Das waren seine hauptsächlichen Beiträge. Die langen Recherchen,
die dann später auch Einzug erhalten haben bei Netzpolitik.org,
die wurden eher auch von anderen getrieben.
Was nicht heißen soll, dass er da nicht seinen Beitrag zu geleistet hat,
aber so vom Typ her war Markus eben einfach mal Blogger durch und durch.
Ja, er war in der Lage es spontan auf den Punkt zu bringen und da ist er ja
dann eben auch als Ansprechpartner für die Medien dann eben zu einer festen
Größe erwachsen, weil er halt einfach schnell erfassen konnte,
okay, das ist jetzt hier sozusagen die politische Kernaussage,
die jetzt hier gerade unter der Lupe ist und dazu hätte ich mal folgende Anmerkung zu machen.
Genau. Das ist eine Fähigkeit, die nicht jedem liegt.
Ne, und die hat er wirklich enorm gut drauf und die ja glaube ich auch sicherlich
bei seiner Koalition der Republika eine Rolle spielt,
dass er halt die ja bei aller Gebreite des Programmes doch schon durchaus immer,
also gut bei der Breite ist es nicht so schwer, aber die schon die relevanten
Themen immer abbildet, ja und ja.
Das auch sehr, sehr gut macht und diese netzpolitischen Diskussionen ebenfalls
breit prägt und wiedergibt.
Und ja, kann man auf jeden Fall sagen, Markus, haben wir da eine ganze Menge
zu verdanken und sicherlich nicht zuletzt auch Logbuch Netzpolitik,
weil wer weiß, wenn ich damals nicht Praktikant bei Netzpolitik.org gewesen
wäre und Redakteur bei Netzpolitik.org, ob wir irgendwie jemals dazu gekommen
wären, diesen Podcast zu machen.
Nö, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das hat sehr viel fruchtbaren Nährboden für sehr viele Menschen gebracht,
was Markus da geschaffen hat.
Aber er wird erhalten bleiben, er macht die Republika weiter,
plant jetzt wohl offenbar noch ein anderes Festival und so.
Wobei ja so für so einen digitalen Menschen, ich hab die Schreibrechte abgegeben,
schon so ein bisschen klingt wie so eine Inschrift auf dem Grabstein. ein, ne? Also,
Wenn ich die Schreibrechte abgebe.
Ich hätte jetzt, also das hätte jetzt auch nicht unbedingt, also warte mal,
ich versuche mich da mal eben einzuloggen.
Vielleicht kann ich ihm die einfach wiedergeben.
Nee, ich komme da auch nicht mehr so ohne weiteres drauf. Die haben da jetzt
auch mal endlich eine HT-Access Sperre auf dem Login.
Ja, also Also, ähm...
Markus Becke da, vielen, vielen Dank. Es gibt zwei schöne Artikel, einmal von ihm,
wo er Netzpolitik.org dankt, einmal von Netzpolitik.org, wo sie ihm danken und
jetzt gibt es ein Trackback von uns, sofern WordPress das noch unterstützt,
wo wir ihm auch nochmal danken.
Wir haben ja beide auch vor wenigen Tagen noch persönlich getroffen und da auch
unsere Glückwünsche und unsere Anerkennung übermeldet.
So, also ich weiß ja nicht, Tim, ob du es mitbekommen hast, aber Daniela Klette.
Der Name war mir ehrlich gesagt kein Begriff.
Nö, ich glaube eigentlich die meisten Namen der sogenannten dritten Generation
waren ja nicht so bekannt wie die der ersten und zweiten Generation der Roten Armee Fraktion.
Ja, also Bader-Meinhof, Ensslin und so diese ganze Runde, die Namen sind ja sehr bekannt.
Dann kommen glaube ich so, wir werden dann noch so Jan Karlraspe,
Christian Klarholger-Mainz sind dann noch bekannte Vertreterinnen der Roten Armee Fraktion.
Aber die sogenannte dritte Generation der RAF, also die als zweite,
die alle um die Landshut-Geschichte drumherum waren,
haben es nicht mehr zu so viel Ruhm geschafft.
Wobei dieser Ruhm natürlich insgesamt auch relativ zweifelhaft ist.
Jedenfalls hörte ich relativ verspätet ein paar weitere Episoden eines Podcasts,
in dem ich auch selber zu Gast war.
Und zwar war das der Podcast Legion Hacking Anonymous.
Ja, das war eine, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, sechsteilige Produktion, so von Studio Bummens,
eine ziemlich gute oder umtriebige Podcast-Produktionsbude, so um Cash Rauberos,
Patrick Stegemann,
Seraphine Dinges.
Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, ob die da alle wirklich, also da arbeiten auch so
ein bisschen Lose zusammen, aber die haben schon die ein oder andere echt aufwendige,
coole Produktion hinter sich, denke ich, kann man so sagen.
Und da gab es das irgendwie zu Hacking, zu Anonymous,
wo sie sich ein bisschen mit diesem Kollektiv oder dieser Idee Anonymous auseinandergesetzt
haben in sechs Episoden und ich glaube in einer davon kam ich auch so ein bisschen
zum Thema Hacking zu Wort.
Und jetzt kommt da auf einmal eine neue Staffel quasi.
Das ist eine aufwendig über Monate produzierte True Crime im weitesten Sinne.
Und jetzt kommen die hin und fügen dem Ding zwei Folgen hinzu.
Und zwar Legion Most Wanted.
Wo ist die RAF-Terroristin Daniela Klette?
Und das beginnt damit, dass ein Hörer denen irgendwie eine E-Mail schreibt und
sagt, ey, ihr habt doch hier diesen Anonymous-Podcast gemacht und mir ist da
echt was Irres passiert. Ich war auf einem,
auf einer Geburtstagsparty im Anonymous-Umfeld und da war eine Frau,
die dann irgendwie zu fortgeschrittener Stunde das,
Fahndungsplakat der RAF rausholt und auf Daniela Klette zeigt und sagt, sie wäre das.
Und wollte euch dem nicht mal,
annehmen.
Eine Frau, die selber gesagt hat, sie sei die die auf der Suche ist.
Du kennst das,
man sitzt da feuchtfröhlich zusammen in kleiner clandestiner politischer Runde
und feiert einen Geburtstag und Leute outen sich als Terroristen und plötzlich
outet sich die ein oder andere als Terroristin as you do,
und dann nehmen die sich dieser Sache an und ich muss ehrlich sagen,
also ich habe diese beiden Folgen verspätet gehört, die sind glaube ich irgendwie
im Dezember erschienen oder nee, die erste im Dezember und die zweite am 9., nee,
nein, beide im Dezember. So.
Und ich hab die aber verspätet gehört irgendwann im Februar.
Weiß gar nicht genau wieso, aber ich hab die später gehört.
Und ich muss sagen, dass ich mich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich darüber aufgeregt
habe, weil sie, also dann irgendwie diese,
Frau, die da von sich behauptet hat, sie wäre wäre Daniela Klette,
da stellt sich dann im weiteren Verlauf raus, dass sie das wohl nicht ist.
Die hat da wahrscheinlich einfach ein bisschen, wird dann ein bisschen interviewt
zu dem Thema und sagt dann so, ja hier.
Nee, aber ich war so in dem Umfeld bin ich groß geworden oder so.
Hat sich ein bisschen dicke getan oder derjenige, der da diese Podcast da auf
sie angesetzt hat, hat vielleicht falsche Erinnerungen gehabt oder so.
Jetzt haben die aber, Und im Rahmen dieser Recherche, weil die machen das ja
schon ordentlich, mit jemandem vom Bellingcat gesprochen und haben einfach mal in PimEyes,
in dieser Gesichtersuchmaschine, danach suchen lassen.
Und Bellingcat ist ja so ein, könnte man sagen, so ein O-Sint-Recherche-Kollektiv.
Die nutzen diese ganzen öffentlich verfügbaren Informationen,
so auch in diesem Fall PimEyes.
Und dieser kanadische Journalist sagt dann so, ja ne, ich hab mal hier in dieser
Gesichtersuchmaschine geguckt, die Frau da in Köln, die ist das nicht, aber die hier ist das.
Und sagt irgendwie, hier gibt es eine Capoeira-Schule in Kreuzberg und die Frau,
die da auf dieser Facebook-Seite von dieser Capoeira-Schule ist, das ist Daniela Klette.
Und dann gehen die in diesen Podcast dahin und sagen, ja okay,
dann gehen wir jetzt halt mal in diese Capoeira-Schule, machen da so eine Stunde
mit, finden die da nicht Fragen nach ihr?
Und der sagt, der Capoeira-Vortänzer oder was sagt dann, ja ne,
die war früher öfter mal hier, aber ist irgendwann nicht mehr gekommen.
Also haben ein Bild gezeigt sozusagen.
Das hing da wohl auch rum in der Capoeira-Schule. Also irgendwie haben die da
Fotos gemacht, da war sie drin. drin.
So, und dann beenden die das und sagen, ja okay, Podcast zu Ende,
wir haben jetzt hier zwei wildfremde unschuldige Personen, einfach mal beschuldigt,
gesuchte Terroristin zu sein, aber wir haben uns entschieden,
man muss ja auch mal veröffentlichen, dass nicht jede Recherche was wird, okay, ciao.
Und ich dachte mir so, ey, das kannst du doch nicht veröffentlichen,
also es ist doch wirklich,
also hatte ich meine Probleme mit und irgendwie so drei Tage,
nachdem ich das gehört habe, irgendwie so Daniela Klette erwischt,
war auf der Facebook-Seite von der Capoeira-Schule und die war das einfach.
Die hatten halt Recht.
Und wussten es nicht.
Und da habe ich mich ehrlich gesagt sogar noch so ein bisschen,
fand ich halt auch kritikwürdig, weil sie so ein bisschen sagen so,
wir wissen es nicht, kann doch sein, dass es ist.
YOLO, ciao, goodbye, frohe Weihnachten.
Und ja, ich hatte meine Schwierigkeiten mit dieser Publikation.
Aber Aber, ja, irgendwie, wann war das?
Mitte Februar oder wann, fand dann eine Verhaftung statt von Daniela Klette
in Kreuzberg, ja, in Kreuzberg, Berlin.
Und die hat da offensichtlich in letzter Zeit,
wie lange weiß man nicht, gesucht wurde sie glaube ich 30 Jahre lang oder so,
hat die in Kreuzberg rumgehangen und hat da offenbar ein halbwegs unbehelligtes Leben geführt.
So, in weiterer Folge haben sie dann jetzt auch noch nach den anderen gesucht.
Insbesondere haben sie ja den Burkhard Garwig dann mit Bildern gesucht.
Ich würde jetzt mal vorsichtig vermuten, dass sie die aktuellen Bilder von Burkhard
Gawig vielleicht, das ist eine Spekulation von mir, von einem Handy hatten,
was sie Daniela Klette weggenommen haben.
Weil auf einmal hatten sie, kurz nachdem sie Daniela Klette hatten,
hatten sie aktuelle Bilder von Burkhard Gawig und offenbar auch Hinweise auf
seinen Aufenthaltsort, weil sie ja dann noch weitere Türen eingetreten haben.
Was vielleicht auch da eine wilde Spekulation damit zu tun haben könnte,
dass Handys Fotos mit Geotechs machen.
Aber das ist jetzt wirklich Spekulation von mir, da habe ich keine Einblicke.
Auf jeden Fall irre Story, Alter.
Ich finde das absolut irre. Zumal ja dann die Polizei hingegangen ist und sich
gerühmt hat, dass sie mit ihrem Dank 30 Jahre vorsichtiger Arbeit und genau,
wir lassen hier nichts mit uns machen.
Und dann war nämlich der, der Kesch Rauberos war auf einmal unter Druck,
dass er dann gefragt wurde, habt ihr mit der Polizei kooperiert?
Und da musste er natürlich als Journalist so sagen, so, äh, nee,
Und nee, so nein haben wir nicht.
Wir haben natürlich ein paar Fragen an die gestellt, aber wir kooperieren als
Journalisten natürlich nicht mit der Polizei und glaube ich auch,
dass die nicht zur Polizei gegangen sind und gesagt haben, ey Leute,
wollt ihr nicht mal gucken?
Ich glaube, wir haben die Daniela Klette. Aber sie haben halt einen Podcast
veröffentlicht, wo sie mehr oder weniger sehr einfach nachvollziehbar das rausgehauen
haben, was ich eben daran auch ein bisschen kritisch fand,
weil irgendwie so, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Capoeira-Schulen es in Berlin gibt,
aber es sind wahrscheinlich nicht so viele wie Yoga-Studios,
wo ich sagen würde, das ist eine nicht eindeutige Angabe.
Aber okay, wie gesagt, ich meine, wenn du am Ende recht behältst, kannst du sowas machen.
Was sie ja gemacht haben, ist eigentlich nur zu zeigen, es gibt diese Recherchemöglichkeiten.
Aber stell dir mal vor, das hätte auch anders ausgehen können,
dass jetzt irgendwie die Leute irgendwelche Internet-Naseweise herausfinden, wer da gemeint ist.
Und dann irgendeine komplett unbescholtene Capoeira-Tänzerin fertig machen und
sie bezichtigen, eine Terroristin zu sein.
Also ich fand das, vielleicht bin ich da auch überempfindlich,
aber ich fand diese Podcast-Veröffentlichung, als ich sie gehört habe,
habe ich gedacht, das kannst du eigentlich nicht machen.
Aber okay, das war auch nur mein persönlicher Einblick und wie gesagt,
der Erfolg gibt ihnen recht Ich mein.
Also ich hab mal grad mal diese PimEyes Webseite mal ausprobiert und einfach
mal mein eigenes Gesicht da reingeschmissen Und?
Bist du Raftterrorist oder nicht?
Ich,
Ich kann mich da jetzt nicht zu äußern.
Auf jeden Fall, also ist überhaupt gar kein Problem, mich zu finden.
Also so gefühlt wirklich, aber auch wirklich in jedem Scheiß Foto,
wo ich auch nur ansatzweise drauf bin und ich würde mal sagen,
eine ganze Menge der URLs, die hier angedeutet werden, die man jetzt nicht klicken
kann, ohne da zu bezahlen. Ähm,
Da wusste ich auch gar nicht, dass ich da irgendwie drauf bin.
Also auf irgendwelchen Stadionfotos bin ich dann irgendwie so zu sehen.
Was?
Halb überdeckt, ja.
Okay.
Ja. Also und ich habe jetzt nur so ein Bild mal hochgeladen,
wo ich so halbwegs okay drauf zu erkennen bin.
Aber das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre alt und findet definitiv auch die älteren
Fotos von mir. Also das funktioniert exzellent.
Und vor allem nicht ein einziges Foto, was ich nicht bin.
Okay, bei mir erkennt er gar nicht, dass er sagt, das wäre kein Gesicht.
Was hast du für eine Fresse.
Wie sieht das denn aus? Nee, man darf da nur hübsche Menschen hochladen.
Naja, auf jeden Fall eine irre Geschichte und ja, jetzt ist halt Frau Klette
ausfindig gemacht worden Und zwei weitere, die noch flüchtig sind,
sind sozusagen on the run.
Wird man noch sehen, ob das auch noch zu Fahndungserfolgen führt.
Aber was lernen wir da jetzt daraus? Warum erwähnen wir das Ganze?
Einfach um mal klar zu machen,
dass die vor vielen Jahren von uns vielleicht noch so als theoretische Möglichkeit
mal in den Raum gestellte Funktionalität jetzt quasi da ist.
Also es ist einfach möglich eine Person zu finden und das finde ich ja hier so bemerkenswert.
Das Foto, mit dem sie das gefüttert haben, war das alte Fahndungsfoto.
Ja, da bin ich zum Beispiel, also ich habe darüber mit Kantorke gesprochen,
der ja genau zum Thema biometrische Massenüberwachung im Logbuch auch schon zu Gast war. Ja.
Und der hat mir gesagt, mit dem normalen Fahndungsfoto würde man sie nicht finden.
Ich habe es aber selber nicht ausprobiert.
Deswegen muss ich da jetzt einfach mal mit, das kann ich das erstmal nur so
wiedergeben. Ich wusste aber auch nicht, wie einfach das ist.
Also ich habe hier tatsächlich jetzt auch, krass, es gibt ja Bilder von mir,
die ich echt nicht kannte.
Ja, so ging es mir auch.
Also ich glaube, da müssen wir was gegen unternehmen.
Also ich meine, sowieso, die Gefahren, also ich meine, die ganze Geschichte
erzählen wir jetzt sowieso nur, um vor den Gefahren biometrischer Gesichterkennung
zu warnen, muss man ja einfach mal ganz klar sagen.
Aber es kann auch sein, dass das vielleicht abgeschaltet wurde,
vielleicht hat die inzwischen ein GDPR-Komplaint bei PimEyes eingereicht oder so.
Aber also relativ sicher hat dieser Bellingcat-Journalist jetzt nichts gemacht,
was nicht jeder andere mit ein bisschen Mühe auch hätte machen können.
Es gab dann weiterhin Diskussionen also Thilo Jung hat ja dann zum Beispiel
auch in der Bundespressekonferenz als sie da ihren Erfolg feierten auch gesagt
so, ja was ist denn daran so schwer, das haben die Podcaster doch schon vor zwei Monaten gemacht so,
und also und dann gab es aber Diskussionen darüber, dass die Polizei sagt,
sie dürfte dieses Tool nicht verwenden was ich ähm.
Und was ich nicht genau beurteilen kann, ob das wahr ist oder nicht.
Also ich fände es gut, wenn sie es nicht dürfen ohne weiteres,
weil das ist ja schon ein höchst kritikwürdiges Produkt, dieses PIM-Eis.
Und es ist jetzt, sag ich mal, für den Kampf gegen biometrische Massenüberwachung
nicht unbedingt positiv, dass es jetzt diesen Ermittlungserfolg gibt.
Ja, also selbst wenn das jetzt etwas ist, was am Ende zur Überführung einer
Terroristin beigetragen hat,
heißt das nicht, dass eine solche Technologie unterm Strich netto positive Konsequenzen
für eine Gesellschaft hat?
Nee, weil in diesem Moment sind es natürlich einfach Demonstranten und Leute,
die gegen die Industrie protestieren oder sonst irgendwie.
Nur kurz um ein Beispiel zu nehmen, bei diesen Massendemonstrationen in Reaktion
auf die Korrektivrecherche,
die ja eine der wichtigsten politischen Enthüllungen, Recherchen oder sonst
was, der letzten Jahre ist,
die dann zu massenhaften Demonstrationen gegen diese grundgesetzfeindlichen
Bestrebungen aus dem engsten Kreis der AfD geführt haben.
Da wurden ja auch Leute fotografiert und gefilmt.
Insbesondere bei den kleinen Demonstrationen hast du die sogenannte Anti-Antifa
da gehabt, die eben Leute fotografiert.
Das ist völlig normal, dass du bei Demonstrationen gegen Rechtsextreme fotografiert wirst. ist.
Insbesondere, wenn es sich, wenn du dich in dem Kreise befindest, wo es.
Oder in Bereichen befindest, wo du zu den wenigen Mutigen gehörst und nicht
zu denen, für die erst 100.000 auf die Straße gehen müssen, damit sie sich als
Schaulustige mit darunter trauen.
Und da sieht das dann schon sehr schnell ganz anders aus, wenn solche Tools in deren Hände sind.
Und da plötzlich jeder Demonstrationsteilnehmer von jedem selbsternannten Anti-Antifa
mal eben erkannt werden kann und dann in den jeweiligen Gruppen,
in denen Angriffe auf Menschen und Belästigungen von Menschen koordiniert werden, plötzlich kursieren.
Das ist eine Gefahr, die nicht theoretisch ist, die wir mit dem NSU 2.0 bei
weiß ich nicht wie viel hundert Leuten gesehen haben.
Mit dem selbsternannten NSU 2.0. Also das ist alles wirklich eine Gefahrtechnologie.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch so, the ship has sailed.
Also das ist jetzt sozusagen eine Technologie, die ist da und diese Datenbanken
sind da und ich glaube, die gehen auch so schnell nicht wieder weg.
Ist wirklich knifflig, wie man jetzt hier dem Missbrauch oder Gebrauch da noch
nennenswert Herr werden soll.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Problem.
Ja
Tja, also Wahnsinnsgeschichte und Podcasts. Der Podcast ist natürlich empfohlen,
auch sei es nur, um sich das Ding mal anzuhören.
Aber ich fand das wirklich irre.
Aber jetzt gibt es ja den AI-Act. Da wird doch alles gut.
Ja, also genau.
Der AI-Act wurde jetzt so beschlossen.
Bis zuletzt wollten ja eigentlich,
also in seiner ursprünglichen Positionierung, wollte das Parlament dieser biometrischen
Massenüberwachung potenziell ein vollständiges Verbot überhelfen.
Ja, das wird so nicht sein.
Es sind jetzt viele Begründungen zugelassen, Menschen zu überwachen,
anhand körperlicher Merkmale zu identifizieren,
das auch mit Hilfe von öffentlichen Kameras und das soll teilweise sogar in
Echtzeit erlaubt werden, wenn die Annahme besteht,
dass etwas Schlimmes passieren könnte.
Also sehr geringe Anforderungen an die Begründungen.
Und da gab es also im Trilog kaum Einschränkungen der Wünsche der Mitgliedstaaten.
Das wird jetzt noch potenziell noch vor den EU-Wahlen in Kraft treten und dann
werden, dann in zwei Jahren werden diese Regeln greifen.
Und jetzt könnten die Mitgliedstaaten auf nationaler Ebene strengere Regeln
erlassen, als es von der Verordnung vorgesehen ist.
Zum Beispiel für diese biometrische Überwachung.
Die Ampelregierung hat angekündigt zumindest eine Echtzeitüberwachung nicht
zu wollen ja also das ist ich denke es wäre schon nicht schlecht gewesen da mehr,
Einschränkungen zu haben weil diese Technologie jetzt auch noch direkt in Echtzeit
auf die Leute loszulassen.
Ja wobei Echtzeit heißt ja eigentlich auch nur möglichst sofort Und zehn Minuten
später ist meistens auch noch sofort genug und ist dann schon schnell wieder
aus der Reglementierung rausgenommen.
Also das wird schon einfach genutzt werden.
So richtig verhindert wurde dadurch jetzt nichts.
Ja, also da wurde auf jeden Fall die,
also ich denke, man kann sich über vieles in diesem AI-Kram Gedanken machen,
aber ich glaube eine biometrische Überwachung des öffentlichen Raumes erstmal
ohne große Einschränkungen zuzulassen,
ist folgenschwer und Und ein klarer Fall von einem Risiko, das man sich gar
nicht erst vorstellen kann.
Ich habe es immer wieder gesagt, dass das ermöglicht dann im öffentlichen Raum
das Tracking, wie wir es aus dem Internet kennen. Und das ist...
Wirklich problematisch.
Hört auf Daniela Klette.
Daniela Klette kann ein Lied davon singen.
Gut. Kommen wir zu anderen problematischen Nutzungen von Technologie.
Unsere Freunde von der Bundeswehr.
Du hast das ja mit Pavel im UKW behandelt. Ihr habt euch allerdings mehr mit
den Inhalten dieses Taurus-Gespräches auseinandergesetzt.
Genau.
Was war passiert?
Was war passiert? Also es ging hier um ein vorbereitendes Gespräch von vier,
Bundeswehrmitgliedern, deren Namen ich jetzt schon wieder nicht parat habe.
Vielleicht findest du die Liste noch kurz.
Das ist nochmal ganz interessant zu sehen. Das war also schon auch...
Also Leute, die was zu sagen haben und es sollte halt ein Treffen vorbereitet
werden mit dem Verteidigungsminister Pistorius,
wo es nochmal um diese Taurus Marschflugkörper geht.
Das ist ja so ein System, was nur Deutschland hat und in einer gewissen Menge
vorrätig ist und seit längerer Zeit ganz oben auf der Wunschliste der Ukraine steht,
weil natürlich mit diesem System es möglich ist, die Russen auf eine Art und
Weise zu treffen, wie es mit den anderen Systemen so nicht geht.
Und das Ganze ist natürlich jetzt im Zentrum einer hitzigen politischen Debatte.
Bei diesem Vorbereitungsgespräch ging es im Wesentlichen darum.
Nochmal die technischen Grundlagen und die logistischen Herausforderungen darzustellen.
Sollte es denn doch irgendwann noch eine politische Entscheidung für solche
Lieferungen geben, die es halt bisher nicht gab und die sich auch im Kontext
dieses Gesprächs nicht abgezeichnet hat.
Ja und jetzt war es aber so, dass diese Leute,
die sich dort unterhielten, nicht in einem abhörsicheren Raum saßen,
sondern quer verteilt über die Welt und ein Teilnehmer war zu dem Zeitpunkt
in Singapur und die ganze Diskussion lief über das Konferenzsystem WebEx,
was im Wesentlichen eigentlich ein internetbasiertes und dann entsprechend auch
mit Verschlüsselung ausgestattetes Konferenzsystem ist.
Allerdings wurde hier die Möglichkeit gewählt, dass man sich auch per Telefon zuschalten kann,
weil es offensichtlich einem der Teilnehmer nicht möglich war oder vielleicht
sind es auch mehr als einer, ich weiß es jetzt nicht ganz genau,
es gab da verschiedene Darstellungen, irgendwie nicht möglich war über das Internet
teilzunehmen, was mich ehrlich gesagt verwundert, hat, weil...
Kann mir keiner erzählen, dass diese Personen nicht mit Smartphones ausgerüstet
sind, wo man mal eben auch selbstverständlich per Smartphone und Internetverbindung,
gerade in Singapur sollte es genug Internet geben,
bin ich mir eigentlich relativ sicher, daran teilnehmen kann.
Stattdessen wurde halt ein Telefonzugang genommen und das Problem mit dem Telefonnetzwerk
ist nun mal, dass dort Verschlüsselung nicht standardmäßig aktiviert ist,
sondern nicht existent ist.
Und mit Telefonverbindungen, die aus Singapur initiiert werden und dann Einwahlknoten,
ich weiß gar nicht wo diese Einwahlknoten waren,
ob das deutsche Einwahltelefonnummern waren oder vielleicht sogar amerikanische,
kann ich gerade nicht sagen, wo auch immer sie sind, bevor man zu diesem Einwahlknoten
kommt, durchläuft man mindestens eben Verteilungssysteme in Singapur.
Und in diesem Fall eben wahrscheinlich auch internationale Netzknoten und naja,
unverschlüsselte Telefonie wird einfach weltweit an zahlreichen Orten abgehört.
Und so ist es den Russen gelungen, dieses Gespräch vollständig bezuschneiden
und fanden dann den Inhalt so putzig, dass sie das dann auch genüsslich veröffentlicht
haben, offensichtlich mit dem Ziel,
Kanzler Scholz hier noch mehr in Zugzwang zu bringen, sich nochmal ganz klar
zu seiner Entscheidung zu bekennen, diese Taurus-Lieferung nicht zu genehmigen,
was er ja dann auch getan hat,
wie es eben die Russen geheißen haben.
Also der Grad an ähm,
Wie soll man denn das nennen? Also ich weiß nicht, ist es Nachlässigkeit,
ist es Inkompetenz, ist es, was ist es denn eigentlich?
Das ist Fahrlässigkeit, die in keiner Form zu entschuldigen ist.
Also das, ja, kannst du nicht erklären.
Ich finde übrigens nur, also offenbar, also zwei Teilnehmer kenne ich.
Das ist der Brigadegeneral Frank Gräfe und der Inspekteur der Luftwaffe Ingo
Gerhards und zwei Offiziere.
Weil du mich gerade noch gebeten hattest, die Namen zu recherchieren.
Die Offiziere finde ich jetzt spontan nicht.
Und ich glaube, es hat sich dann herausgestellt, dass offenbar der Gräfe,
der da in Singapur war, sich unsicher eingewählt hatte.
Aber dass auch der Inspekteur der Luftwaffe, Ingo Gerhards, ebenfalls sich nicht
richtig eingewählt hatte.
Also nicht mit dem, nicht mit der, für den Dienstgebrauch zertifizierten Variante eingewählt hat.
So, und jetzt frage ich mich, wieso kann die Bundeswehr diese,
wieso haben die überhaupt diese Option an, dass man sich per Telefon damit einwählen kann?
Also, das kann ich mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, weil ich bin mir relativ
sicher, dass das ein deaktivierbares Feature ist.
Zur Frage, es hat eventuell nicht funktioniert. Tja, wieso wohl nicht,
wenn einer auf der Leitung hängt?
Das könnte eine Sache sein. Außerdem, ich habe nicht viele Erfahrungen mit WebEx,
aber ich kann sagen, dass es von allen Möglichkeiten des Videoconferencing diejenige
ist, die ich am allerwenigsten mag.
Und diejenige, wo ich am häufigsten feststelle, dass Leute sich auch übers Telefon
einwählen, teilweise auch einfach deshalb, weil es geht.
Also warum geht das überhaupt? Warum?
Warum? Und meistens werden die Leute sich dann von Telefonen einwählen,
dann nutzen sie die Mute-Taste nicht und so weiter, aber okay,
ich will jetzt nicht schon wieder in meinen Rant über,
Mehrpersonentelefonie,
ausbrechen.
Also es geht natürlich deshalb, weil die Leute manchmal einfach kein Breitband-Internet haben.
Genau, aber ja, in Singapur ist das eher unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, das ist in der Tat.
Ein entwickeltes Land. Ja, aber also es ist Es ist hochnotpeinlich und wenn
du dir überlegst, was Militäre dieser Welt ausgegeben haben über die Zeiten,
In Verschlüsselung. Ich meine, wir können froh sein, dass die Deutschen keine
Funktion, oder eine Schwachstelle in der Verschlüsselung der Enigma hatten.
Das hat nach allem, was man historisch weiß, einen entscheidenden Beitrag geleistet
dazu, dass die scheiß Nazis den Krieg verloren haben.
Also die Bedeutung von Verschlüsselung sollte Militären seit jeher bekannt sein.
Insbesondere den Deutschen.
Insbesondere den Deutschen, die sollten sich an eine, also da gibt es überhaupt
keine Entschuldigung für.
Überhaupt keine Entschuldigung für. Null.
Ja, aber haben sie gemacht und ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Also ich meine, du hast schon recht, also es ist sowohl die Frage,
warum wird es bereitgestellt und B, warum wird es dann auch noch gemacht,
wenn es bereitgestellt wird.
Mir war übrigens so, aber das habe ich offensichtlich falsch gelesen oder falsch
in Erinnerung, dass irgendwie noch nachher behauptet wurde,
es wäre noch nicht mal jemand auf der Leitung gesessen,
sondern es sei passiert, dass sie einfach eine weitere Person eingewählt hat
und niemand sich gewundert hat, dass da einer mehr im Call ist.
Aber das lese ich jetzt nicht im Wikipedia-Artikel, bei dem ich davon ausgehe,
dass jede gesicherte, stabile Information sich darin wiederfindet.
Ja, das habe ich als Vermutung auch gelesen, aber kenne dafür keine Bestätigung.
Ja, also hielte ich potenziell für die noch wahrscheinlichere Variante,
aber genau, also aktueller Stand ist das zumindest nicht bestätigt.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall das,
Problem ist hier glaube ich einfach, dass die Bundeswehr nicht alert genug ist,
also die laufen hier noch in einem bürokratischen Trott der,
im Wesentlichen hier so wir machen hier so ein bisschen Militärsimulationen,
den Eindruck macht. Also sie sind nicht im Kriegsmodus.
Das ist das, was mich so ein bisschen verstört dabei.
Also sagen wir mal, Konfliktmodus wäre mir lieber. Also ich hoffe nicht,
dass sie in den Kriegsmodus kommen.
Aber Ja, wir haben aber gerade Krieg. Also man muss in dem Kriegs,
also als Bundeswehr muss man gerade im Kriegsmodus sein, weil wir haben da gerade
ein Land, was täglich im Fernsehen ankündigt, dass sie irgendwie Atomraketen
auf Berlin schicken wollen.
Also wenn Wenn dann die Bundeswehr nicht dann im Kriegsmodus ist,
dann frage ich mich, wann die im Kriegsmodus ist.
Also mal ehrlich, man kann es ja aus der Politik irgendwie noch versuchen rauszuhalten,
um die Bevölkerung nicht zu beunruhigen.
Aber innerhalb der Bundeswehr sollte man da einfach ausreichend beunruhigt sein.
Man sollte zumindest ausreichend sensibilisiert sein, hier nicht noch die Dinge
schlimmer zu machen, als sie ohnehin sind.
Zum Beispiel, indem man interne Talking Points einfach so preisgibt,
weil die halt politisch und informationstechnisch genutzt werden können.
So und ich meine, was haben wir hier schon über Security-Angriffe auf dem Bundestag
und so weiter gesprochen,
wo mit Hightech und finstersten Hacker-Methoden und Zero-Day-Exploits und die
also findigsten Methoden sozusagen schon die Geheimnisebene dieses Staates aufgebohrt wird.
Aber wenn man dann halt einfach sagt, ja ich nehme jetzt einfach mal Telefon,
dann muss man sich auch einfach über gar nichts mehr wundern.
Nein, also da sind noch keine Köpfe gerollt.
Also wenn du das nicht machst, dann brauchst du dich über gar nichts mehr zu wundern.
Oder? Also das Gut Natürlich hat es auch Also natürlich müssen wir trotzdem
jetzt diese Sache ordentlich untersuchen Na, aber,
Ey, Verschlüsselung Ich find's allein schon irre Also ich find's eigentlich
schon irre, dass die überhaupt WebEx nutzen Wobei das ja bei,
sinnvoller Anwendung potenziell Vielen Dank.
Wahrscheinlich für ein solches Gespräch eine ausreichende Sicherheit bieten würde.
Ich weiß nicht, ist jetzt ein Webex irgendwas speziell schlecht, was ich nicht weiß?
Maximal Scheiße zu bedienen.
Okay, gut, aber es ist an sich das Feature, wir haben eine verschlüsselte Verbindung, haben sie schon.
Also sollte jetzt, würde ich dem Ding schon zutrauen.
Francisco ist das System, muss man dazu nochmal sagen. Tja, naja gut,
also so, ja, als Kopfschüttel haben wir jetzt hier gerade nicht bereit, oder?
Haben wir noch irgendeinen nennenswerten Kommentar dazu abzugeben?
Nee, nee, hast recht. Wir könnten jetzt noch ein paar Minuten weiter uns an
den Kopf fassen, aber das machen wir einfach nach der Sendung noch ein bisschen.
Aber du fragst dich doch echt.
Ey. Tja, so ist es. Wir dienen Deutschland.
Aber nicht besonders gut.
So, mal vielleicht ein bisschen was aus der Abteilung, etwas bessere Nachrichten.
Ah ja, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Genau. Es gibt da einen Menschen, Karl Malamuth,
ich weiß nicht, ob du von dem schon mal gehört hast, Aktivist und Internethistoriker,
der zwar aus den USA kommt und dort unter anderem das Projekt publicresource.org gegründet hat.
Und unter anderem auch in den USA schon mit Klagen dafür gesorgt hat,
dass Normen und Standards,
die in Gesetzen verwendet werden, auch der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht werden sollen.
Und hatte da auch im letzten September bereits schon Erfolg damit.
Und vor allem geht er spezifisch dagegen vor, dass das Ganze mit dem Urheberrecht begründet werden soll.
Was jetzt also passiert ist, er hat geklagt in der EU und mit der Argumentation, ihr macht Gesetze.
Diese Gesetze beziehen sich auf bestimmte Standards,
aber wenn ich diese Standards einsehen will, dann werde ich von der DIN und
von anderen Normungsinstituten zur Kasse gebeten, weil ich muss ja Geld dafür
bezahlen, wenn ich mir diese Standards vor die Nase halten möchte,
um mal nachzuschauen, was ich denn jetzt eigentlich tun muss,
um diese Gesetze einzuhalten.
Und hat das eben vor den Europäischen Gerichtshof gebracht, über den wir ja
schon öfter berichtet haben, über den EuGH.
In diesem Zusammenhang habe ich übrigens auch nochmal begriffen,
dass der EuGH tatsächlich, also dass das Gerichtssystem der Europäischen Union
tatsächlich aus drei Teilen besteht, von denen es nur zwei Teile gibt.
Hä? Ja, es gibt nämlich den Europäischen Gerichtshof, den EuGH,
Aber es gibt auch noch das Gericht der Europäischen Union, das EUG.
Nicht EUGH, sondern EUG.
Früher wurde es einfach das Gericht der ersten Instanz genannt,
dafür ist es nämlich zuständig.
Und außerdem gibt es noch sogenannte Fachgerichte, die existieren könnten,
aber von denen derzeit noch kein Nutzen gemacht wird im europäischen System.
Themen. Auf jeden Fall Moment.
Könnten wir dann, also könnten wir diese dritte fehlende Instanz jetzt einfach kurz spontan gründen?
Fachgericht für,
verschlüsselte Webkonferenzen. Ja, mal gucken. Also weiß ich nicht.
Genau, also die Argumentation mit der da vorgegangen ist, ist halt das technische
Normen, die Bestandteil europäischer Verordnungen und Richtlinien sind,
dass die für Unternehmen und Bürger kostenfrei zugänglich sein müssen.
Und diese Klage wendet sich halt vor allem gegen die Europäische Kommission
und diese Normungsorganisationen, die also auch hier beteiligt sind.
Also das sind einerseits die verschiedenen Normungsorganisationen in den europäischen
Ländern und das Europäische Komitee für Normung, CIN.
Interessant ist, dass also zunächst einmal sich dieses Gericht der Europäischen
Union dem angenommen hat und das hat diese Klage zurückgewiesen mit dem Hinweis,
weil ja dann die Finanzierung dieser Normungsinstitutionen, Organisationen gefährdet sei.
Ist ja geil.
Und ich meine, man muss ja auch nochmal klar machen, Normen werden halt von
diesen DIN und von anderen Normungsorganisationen in Europa veröffentlicht,
aber nicht vollständig und frei.
Sondern wenn man die dann halt so genau haben will, dann muss man horrende Summen
dafür bezahlen, dass man eine entsprechende Kopie dieser Standards bekommt.
Also wenn ich mir das so mal vorstelle, das Internet hätte sich so nicht durchgesetzt.
Also das war definitiv auf einer anderen Basis gebaut.
Aber in dem Moment, wo man halt in Gesetzen auf entsprechenden Standards verweist,
insbesondere bei den neuen digitalen Gesetzen.
Ist doch völlig selbstverständlich, oder?
Würde man meinen, aber tatsächlich wird halt hier auch immer argumentiert,
dass ja allein schon wegen des Urheberrechts das ja auch nicht ginge.
Wobei halt der Malamuth ganz nachvollziehbar argumentiert,
dass ja diese Normungsgruppen erstmal gar nicht die Urheber seien,
sondern die veröffentlichen das ja nur.
Und dass ohnehin das Urheberrecht nicht diesen Status haben darf,
sondern dass der Recht auf den Zugang zu dem Gesetzestext eigentlich Priorität haben soll.
Und jetzt ist das Ganze dann aber, nachdem es in erster Instanz erstmal zurückgewiesen wurde,
geht es dann eben zum Europäischen Gerichtshof und der hat sich jetzt dazu geäußert
und hat gesagt, sagt so, ja nee, also das kann nicht sein,
dass Standards, die in Gesetzen als Voraussetzung sind,
wo gesagt wird, damit du dieses Gesetz erfüllen kannst, muss folgender Standard
berücksichtigt werden.
Und wenn du dann halt sagen willst, ja was steht denn da drin in dem Stand,
ich würde ja gerne mal überprüfen, ob hier irgendjemand auch das Gesetz einhält,
dass man dann erstmal dafür bezahlen muss, nur um das irgendwie zu machen.
Und das geht halt irgendwie nicht.
Ja, also.
Es ist jetzt noch so ein bisschen unklar, so wie sich das EuGH geäußert hat,
inwieweit das jetzt dann auch sozusagen dieses Urheberrecht-Argument betrifft,
weil sich dazu das EuGH so konkret nicht geäußert hat.
Das heißt, wir müssen einfach nur riesige Gesetze mit Unmengen an urheberrechtlich
geschütztem Material veröffentlichen?
Naja, das ist ja sozusagen nur so ein Argument, um das sozusagen aufrechtzuerhalten.
Also mir ist nicht ganz klar, was jetzt hier der nächste Schritt ist,
aber hier ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Fakt geliefert worden,
weil im Prinzip wird jetzt diese ganze aktuelle Handhabung für nichtig erklärt vom EuGH.
Und jetzt muss hier in irgendeiner Form Abhilfe geschaffen werden.
So, ich finde das, also es sollte auch wirklich einleuchtend sein, oder?
Es sollte einleuchtend sein, allerdings stellt sich natürlich hier eine viel
größere Frage, nämlich wie finanzieren wir denn jetzt die Normungsinstitute künftig?
Also nicht alle Standards, die in diesen Normungsinstituten gehandelt werden,
stehen in irgendwelchen Gesetzen.
Da sind ja jede Schraube und jedes Kabel und Schutzmechanismen und keine Ahnung
alles mögliche, es gibt Standards für jeden Scheiß,
sind da drin und da wird es halt natürlich noch weiterhin so gehandhabt werden können.
Nur Standards, die eben explizit Teil von Gesetzen sind, müssen jetzt eigentlich
kostenlos herausgegeben werden.
Und zwar für die Öffentlichkeit.
Ja.
Das finde ich ist eine ganz gute Nachricht.
Ja, aber das ist auch, also was denn sonst?
Tja.
Ja, irre. Also ich wusste das nicht. Ich wusste nicht, dass es noch nicht so ist.
Umso mehr freue ich mich, dass es jetzt so ist.
Genau, also muss man mal abwarten, was das jetzt tatsächlich auslöst.
Mir ist nicht so ganz klar, was jetzt der nächste Schritt ist in diesem Zusammenhang,
aber so ganz ohne Auswirkungen wird das nicht sein können.
Okay. Dann kommen wir zum letzten Thema.
Und dieses Thema ist eins aus dem kulturellen Bereich, würde ich sagen.
Also das Internet ist bereichert worden durch ein neues Mem.
Ja, welches?
Das ist der Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Okay, das ist dieser Mensch, der Falschpacker aufschreibt oder so?
Also der hat, also es ist eine Spiegel-TV-Doku und Spiegel-TV hat auf,
wenn man so mal deren YouTube-Veröffentlichungen verfolgt, die haben da so durchwachsenes Material.
Also ich glaube, sehr bekannt ist diese Penny an der Reeperbahn.
Kennst du nicht?
Penny an der Reeperbahn?
Also auf der Reeperbahn in Hamburg-St. Pauli befindet sich ein Pennymarkt.
Achso, ja.
Und dieser Pennymarkt hat relativ ausgedehnte Öffnungszeiten und natürlich ein
relativ spezielles Publikum.
Also einerseits Leute, die auf der Reeperbahn unterwegs sind und mal vielleicht
noch irgendwo billig Alkohol kaufen wollen.
Andererseits Leute, die vielleicht auf der Straße wohnen in Hamburg und da Alkohol kaufen.
Aber dann natürlich insgesamt auch.
Es ist ein relativ bunter Bezirk, in dem der ein oder andere Charakter wohnt.
Und in diesem Penny-Markt haben die eine Zeit lang mal so eine Doku gemacht,
in der sie mal so alles wiedergeben, was da so rein und raus läuft.
Dazu relativ belustigt erzählt und es ist auf jeden Fall absolut lustig.
Ja, auch grundsätzlich erstmal eine wertschätzende Stimme, aber man weiß jetzt auch nicht unbedingt,
ob jedem Menschen, der da dargestellt ist oder sich auch darstellt,
ob der unbedingt im Vollbesitz seiner geistigen Kräfte war, als er dem zugestimmt hat.
Oder ob der überhaupt noch im Vollbesitz seiner geistigen Kräfte ist.
Also muss man gesehen haben, ist unglaublich unterhaltsam, ist auch eine sehr
interessante Sozialstudie, aber ich denke, an der kann man auch sehr viel Kritik üben,
weil da mitunter auch wirklich Menschen in katastrophalen Zuständen gezeigt werden. So.
Gleichzeitig haben die relativ viele Recherchen irgendwie, da gibt es ja so
zu Rockermilieu, kriminelles Milieu und so, wie dem auch sei,
haben ein relativ buntes Programm.
Und jetzt haben sie einen jungen Mann begleitet,
der irgendwie 18 Jahre alt ist, mit so einem eindeutig höchst verkehrssicheren
Fahrrad durch die Gegend fährt und dabei irgendwie Signalkleidung trägt und
einen Helm und dann Knöllchen schreibt.
Höhepunkte sind dann irgendwie, dass er jemanden aufschreibt, der,
Irgendwie statt sieben Meter vom Halteverbotsschild sechs Meter siebzig vom
Halteverbotsschild entfernt ist und deswegen 30 Zentimeter im Halteverbot steht
und deswegen jetzt aufgeschrieben wird und dann dokumentiert er das mit so einem Zollstock.
Dann hat er irgendwie vorne ein Schild dran wo irgendwie Pulifzai steht ja,
weil Polizei darfst du nicht dran schreiben.
Wäre Amtsanmaßung sondern da steht was dran Pulifzai ja.
Also und dann wirft ihm jemand Amtsanmaßung oder Täuschung vor,
weil er sich eben auch als Anzeigenhauptmeister,
vorstellt Ja, also wenn er da mit Leuten spricht, dann sagt er irgendwie,
ich bin Anzeigenhauptmeister so und so.
Polizvieh steht drauf.
Polizvieh.
Ja, das ist so ähnlich wie hier in Berlin stand doch mal, steht glaube ich immer
noch, weiß ich gar nicht, so ein altes Polizeiauto, eine Wanne,
auf der dann statt Polizeikanzlei stand. Da hat es so ein Verkehrsrechtler, glaube ich.
Oh, kenne ich mit Politur, aber es gibt verschiedene Varianten.
Ja, genau, es gibt Polenta.
Politur und was man so alles da so draufschreiben kann. So, aber der ist halt
eisenhart und der hat irgendwie um die 4000 Anzeigen geschrieben.
Geht, glaube ich, wohl auch seinem Heimatdorf inzwischen, damit gehöre ich auf den Sack.
Hält sich aber für irgendwie jemanden, der Staatssäcke füllt und hat,
also hat da wirklich ein sehr ausgefallenes Hobby, sagen wir mal. Ja.
So und den haben die mit, ich glaube das ist sogar der gleiche Erzähler,
so da so begleitet in seinem Alltag, wie der dann da so mit den Leuten aneinander gerät,
die dann irgendwie so sagen,
ja ich hab hier so einen Vogel und dann sagt er direkt, das ist eine Beleidigung
und kennt dann irgendwie den Paragrafen und schreibt dann eine Anzeige dafür.
Dann hat er wieder in irgendeinem Falschparker die Polizei bestellt.
Dann hat die Polizei aber ein beschmutztes Nummernschild.
Und dann entblödet er sich nicht, auch noch der Polizei zu sagen,
sie müsste dann jetzt mal langsam das Nummernschild reinigen.
Weil noch ist es erkennbar.
Aber, aber, und der Typ ist natürlich Instant, Instant-Meme,
ja, also der ist so geil, also der ist, du guckst dir das an und du denkst dir so, ist der gut,
aber du weißt auch, das Internet ist undankbar, Tim, ich sage dir,
das Internet ist undankbar.
Weil natürlich ist der Typ jetzt ein Instant-Meme und der wird jetzt rauf und runter gememt und so.
Und statt ihn dankbar zu behandeln, statt dem Internet zu danken.
Ist der natürlich zu absoluten Hassobjekt von irgendwie weiß ich wie vielen Autofahrern geworden.
Und hat dann jetzt auch schon, also wie heißt dieser absolute Vollproll da von YouTube?
Ja, nein, aber der wirkt nicht der Königsbräu.
Achso, ja.
Der Königsbräu von YouTube.
So Namen, die mir Gott sei Dank schnell wieder entfallen.
Montana Black.
Ja, sowas, ja.
Mit so einer Knast drin. Also der Typ, ey. Eine Figur. Der ist ja auch ein Instant-Meme.
Also den guckt man sich ja auch nur an.
Aber, also jedenfalls, der hat dann auch schon prophezeit, dass der früher oder
später auf die Fresse kriegt.
Natürlich. Also ist ja auch klar, ne? Ich meine, natürlich kriegt der früher
oder später auf die Fresse.
Aber natürlich auch, insbesondere, weil Spiegel TV den jetzt da in einer Dreiviertelstundendoku
der Weltöffentlichkeit oder dem deutschen Autofahrer zum Fraß vorgeworfen hat.
Ja, und da hat er natürlich auch… Mit Realnamen.
Ja, ich hab den, also der ist da mit Realnamen, wird über den berichtet.
Ich hab deswegen auch extra seinen Realnamen gerade nicht gesagt,
so, aber Ich auch nicht, aber Der ist mit Realnamen und irgendwie Wohnort und so jetzt im Internet.
Und statt den mal zu feiern, weil ich denk mir so, kann doch nur Gewinner geben.
Also der Typ zeigt einen Autofahrer nach dem anderen an, die rasten aus und
wenn sie den beleidigen oder schlagen, kriegen sie noch eine Anzeige.
Erstmal würde ich sagen, so ey,
the game, not the player. Also der macht das halt, also ich finde das eine...
Also ich kann einen gewissen Unmut der Leute durchaus nachvollziehen.
Natürlich. Ich glaube, der Unmut ist dem auch nicht entgangen.
Der merkt ja, wie die Welt auf ihn reagiert.
Aber ist dem ein bisschen egal?
Also der hält sich dafür auf der der auf der richtigen Seite des Gesetzes ist,
der möchte einfach nur, dass die Leute sich dran halten.
Also sagen wir mal, ich würde noch einen draufsetzen. Ich glaube,
dem ist auch klar, dass er jetzt nicht am Ende des Tages Menschen glücklich
gemacht hat mit seinem Tun.
Und deswegen meine ich auch, gewissermaßen könnte man auch sagen,
der will ja auch auf die Fresse.
Also so, oder der will, sagen wir mal so, der will, dass Leute ihm auf die Fresse hauen wollen.
Weißt du?
Der hat da schon, also man kann da teilweise so eine leichte diebische Freude auch bei erkennen.
Ja, also als er dann das ausmisst so mit den sieben Metern, dann fragt ihn halt
dieser Journalist oder Redakteur oder wer das dann ist. oder so,
muss man das jetzt immer messen?
Und dann sagt er so, nö, kann man auch schätzen.
Aber der hat sich halt verschätzt. So, oder?
Ich finde halt, für so einen muss man dankbar sein. Der treibt ja jetzt niemanden
in den Ruinen. Der schafft ein Thema.
Und ich finde es fürchterlich, dass das Internet nicht die Souveränität hat zu sagen, so.
Guter Typ. So, schaff was, worüber wir uns den Mund zerreißen können.
Schaff was, wo wir uns mit auseinandersetzen können. Gib uns ein Gesprächsthema.
Und ich verstehe es nicht. Ich verstehe es genauso nicht beim Drachenlord,
warum Menschen dann so darauf reagieren.
Wie gesagt, dass der von einem, den er da irgendwie in einer Stresssituation
weiß, da sind Leute, sie sind beim Be- und Entladen vor ihrem eigenen Geschäft.
Und dann kommt er an und sagt, Hallo, ich bin der Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Gebt jetzt eine Anzeige. Und die nehmen den natürlich nicht ernst.
Und dann ruft er halt die Bullen. Und dann kommen die Bullen und sagen,
boah, scheiße, ja, hier 15 Euro.
Lass uns in Ruhe und wollen wieder weg.
Der hat da halt einen Punkt getroffen, wo er trollen kann.
Und damit muss man eben auch, also ich finde, das ist eine Reifeprüfung für
die Menschen, damit umzugehen. und eben nicht die Fassung zu verlieren.
Wie würdest denn du damit umgehen, wenn der dich jetzt laufend im Meta aufschreibt?
Ich bin ein schlechtes Beispiel.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das im Podcast, ich kann das auch nicht erzählen.
Wenn ich das erzähle, dann bin ich dran.
Also dann bin ich dran wegen Beamtenbeleidigungen.
Aber sagen wir mal, ich hab ich hab nach meiner letzten,
nach meinem Nach meinem letzten Strafzettelchen, was mir von so Polizisten ausgestellt wurde,
Bodycount wieder entdeckt. Kennst du Bodycount?
1992, Album.
Achso, Rap? Oder was?
Bodycount ist völlig in Ordnung, kommen auch übrigens dieses Jahr nach Berlin,
Hamburg und so, aber die hatten 1992 ein Album rausgebracht, das sich...
Das sich mit Gewalt gegen Polizisten verherrlichend auseinandergesetzt hat.
Sagen wir das so. Das wurde dann in Deutschland auch, ist in Deutschland schwer
zu bekommen gewesen, sagen wir es mal so.
Und das hast du dann vermehrt gehört.
Weil du unzufrieden warst über den Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Der in dem Fall wirklich ein Hauptmeister war.
Das war ein richtiger Hauptmeister und das war auch so einer.
Aber der Polizei kann ich das in gewisser Hinsicht noch nachsehen.
Ne, das sind also.
Also mit den Gesetzen ist es ja so, die sind dazu da,
um Recht zu definieren und festzustellen und natürlich gibt es Momente,
wo man sozusagen das auch missbrauchen kann.
Ja, also vor allem gibt es erstmal Momente, wo es auch sinnvoll ist,
dass es das gibt und dann ist das sozusagen die Vergleichsgröße,
die man nimmt und damit wird dann eben recht auch entschieden,
wenn mal was Schlimmes passiert ist.
Allerdings, gerade was den Straßenverkehr betrifft.
Ein völlig unterregulierter Bereich, wenn ich das mal sagen darf.
Im Straßenverkehr hier, also ich habe gesagt, wir sprechen nicht drüber,
aber jetzt sprechen wir drüber.
Hier in Berlin, unterregulierter Bereich,
unterentforster Bereich,
du kannst dich an eine Ampel stellen und du kannst dir sicher sein,
dass bei jedes Mal, wenn das da rot wird, noch drei Leute drüber fahren.
Du kannst dich hinstellen und brauchst nicht lange zu warten,
bis irgendwelche Besoffenen zu acht auf irgendeinem Roller auf der falschen
Seite rumfahren und so weiter.
Aber wozu entscheidet sich Berlin, wem wird das Leben in Berlin schwer gemacht? Den Radfahrern.
Da muss ich jetzt wirklich ein bisschen kichern.
Also die wirklich in jeder Statistik die gefährdetsten Verkehrsteilnehmer in
Berlin sind, von denen die geringste Gefährdung ausgeht.
Der Anzeigenhauptmeister konzentriert sich ausschließlich auf Autos?
Ich glaube, der Anzeigenhauptmeister, der drückt keine Augen zu.
Also da kannst du sicher sein, der drückt keine Augen zu.
Dem geht es doch sozusagen ums Prinzip und damit auch egal, welcher Gesetzestext
jetzt hier relevant ist.
Ich würde sagen, der Anzeigenhauptmeister ist nicht bestechlich,
der ist nicht korrumpierbar.
Gut, also wo wir jetzt gerade bei diesem Bereich sind.
Ich habe Hochachtung vor dem.
Ja, also mit den roten Ampeln habe ich in Berlin etwas andere Erfahrungen.
Also ich würde mal sagen, die allermeisten Autos bleiben bei rot stehen, solange bis grün ist.
Und dann fahren sie mit 100 weiter.
Egal, wir waren bei der roten Ampel. Rote Ampeln, finde ich,
haben im Wesentlichen noch ein hohes, wie nennt man das?
Das ist eine der wenigen Dinge, die Autofahrer noch bemüht sind zu respektieren, ja.
Genau, also da ist so die, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das jetzt korrekt quantifiziert,
aber sagen wir mal so, die Mitmachbereitschaft bei diesem Gesetz ist relativ hoch.
Allerdings bei Fahrradfahrern habe ich das Gefühl, überhaupt nicht bekannt,
dass rote Ampeln eigentlich auch für Fahrradfahrer, also bei jeder einzelnen
roten Ampel, wirklich jeder Ampel in Berlin, jede Ampel, wenn ich da stehe, rot,
immer ist auch mindestens einer, wenn nicht zehn Radfahrer dabei,
die komplett zu ignorieren.
Also den Punkt kannst du jetzt wirklich überhaupt nicht aufmachen.
Ich weiß genau, worauf du hinaus willst und ich sage auch nicht,
es ist nicht erforderlich, bestimmte Dinge zu entforcen.
Worauf ich hinaus möchte, ist was anderes.
Also ich habe….
Ist das meiner Auffassung nach nicht im Sinne der Gesetzgebung.
Weil diese Gesetze sind nicht dafür gedacht, permanent überall,
jederzeit, auf jeden angewendet zu werden,
sondern sie sind sozusagen dafür gedacht, um dafür zu sorgen,
dass wir ein Gemeinwohl haben, haben, in dem sich alle weitgehend,
so wie es erforderlich ist, respektieren und Sicherheit gewähren.
Das ist sozusagen das Ziel.
Aber nicht permanent für jede 30 Zentimeter Verfehlung irgendwie zur Kasse gebeten
zu werden, weil das ist dann auch nicht im Sinne der Gesellschaft.
Und das ist das Problem, was die Leute mit dem Anzeigenhauptmeister haben.
Natürlich sollte es nicht dazu führen, dass ihm dann sozusagen Dinge geschehen,
worauf andere Gesetze damit angewendet werden können.
Insofern verstehe ich den Punkt natürlich auch.
Also, zu den roten Ampeln. Ich habe meine Strafen für das Überfahren roter Ampeln
immer mit Fassung bezahlt und mich da nie drüber aufgeregt.
Mit dem Fahrrad?
Ja, ich bin natürlich nur mit dem Fahrrad. Wenn du im Auto über eine rote Ampel
fährst, das kannst du nicht bringen.
Warum nicht?
Das ist verboten.
Okay, gut. Da würden sie mich auch nach dem Führerschein fragen.
Eigentlich beim Fahrradfahren auch.
Ja, also ich habe tatsächlich mal für das Überfahren einer roten Ampel, die lauern ja.
Die stellen ja auch Rotampelfallen. Aber auch das machen sie übrigens für Fahrradfahrer
und nicht für Autofahrer.
Für Autofahrer gibt es sogar richtige Maschinen.
Also pass auf, ich kann dir erklären, was passiert ist. Ich habe während des
Radfahrens an einer Telefonkonferenz teilgenommen.
Was legal ist.
Aber verschlüsselt.
Verschlüsselt, ja. Ja, so. Und ich hatte das Handy in der Tasche,
weil ich ja weiß, dass ich das Handy während der Fahrt nicht bedienen darf.
Und hatte das Ding natürlich auf Mute, weil ich ja weiß, dass ich durch meine
Fahrgeräusche die Telefonkonferenz an ihrem Geschehen störe.
So, dann wurde es mir aber dazu bunt und ich wollte mich zu Wort melden.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt stand ich an einer roten Ampel Und zwar am Alexanderplatz,
Dann habe ich an dieser roten Ampel Was auch mein gutes Recht ist,
Ähm.
Moment, wie war das? Da wurde es grün. Ich hatte mein Handy noch in der Tasche.
Ich bin losgefahren, habe in Vorbereitung meines Einschreitens in diese Telefonkonferenz,
bin ich also nicht auf dem Radweg weitergefahren,
sondern bin dann langsam, also absolut mit Schrittgeschwindigkeit,
auf den Gehweg gerollt, dort zum Stehen gekommen. Ich konnte ja nicht auf der Straße anhalten.
Ich bin also auf dem Gehweg zum Stehen gekommen, habe dabei mein Handy rausgeholt,
mich unmutet und angefangen zu sprechen.
Woraufhin ich mir zwei fahrradfahrende Polizisten auf dem Gehweg entgegen kamen, die zu mir fuhren.
Also schon mal gegen dieses man darf nicht auf dem Gehweg fahren Gesetz.
Übrigens auch auf der falschen Seite mir entgegen kamen.
Außer man ist Polizist.
Genau und dann haben die mich wegen,
Fahren auf dem Gehweg den ich ja wahrscheinlich gute 6 Meter berollt hatte.
6 Meter das sind 6 Meter als erlaubt sind.
6 Meter mehr als erlaubt sind die sind aber 30, 40 Meter zu mir gefahren telefonieren am Steuer,
Und zweifelhafter Beanstandung der Verkehrssicherheit meines Fahrrades mit einem Knöllchen versehen.
Das war dann irgendwie so 100 noch was, 150 Euro oder sowas der Spaß gekostet hat.
Das hatte aber leider noch die bittere Konsequenz,
dass ich zum Wiederherstellen der Verkehrstauglichkeit meines Rades nach deren
Auffassung ein Loch in diesen Fahrradrahmen bohren musste.
Was? Wieso das?
Achso, du hast kein Licht gehabt, oder was?
Nee, natürlich brauchte ich kein Licht an dem Fahrrad zu haben.
Und was musst du da noch reinbohren?
Eine Auffassung für die Hinterradbremse.
Dein Fahrrad hat hinten keine Bremse gehabt?
Selbstverständlich hat mein Fahrrad hinten eine Bremse gehabt.
Ja, aber?
Es gibt in Berlin zwei unterschiedliche Urteile zu der Frage,
ob ein Fixed-Gear-Fahrrad die Anforderungen von zwei unabhängigen Bremssystemen erfüllt oder nicht.
Ah, du bist mit dem Hipster-Bike unterwegs gewesen und daran haben sie sich gestört.
Das Fahrrad, was mein verstorbener Freund als letztes designt hat,
was ich gekauft habe, ja.
Und dieses Fahrrad durfte ich dann auf Anordnung der Polizei beschädigen.
Das war einfach nur, also ganz ehrlich, wenn du meinen Weg zur Arbeit fährst,
das sind sechs Kilometer, sieben Kilometer durch Berlin Mitte,
die kannst du nicht zurücklegen, ohne in Lebensgefahr zu geraten.
Und dass dann da irgendwelche Polizisten ihre Hauptaugenmerk darauf legen,
Radfahrer einfach nur zu schikanieren in Situationen, die in keiner Form…,
in keiner Form irgendeinen Menschen in Gefahr gebracht haben oder sonstiges,
ist einfach also da habe ich verliere ich sämtliches,
Interesse diesen Staat noch weiter zu unterstützen und das ist wirklich Das
ist eine arme Sau, der Typ, der zeigt da, der lässt da ab und zu mal einen Wieso?
Vielleicht waren die von der Polizei ja ja auch arme Säue. Also letzten Endes
ist es aber genau das gleiche.
So, weil er ja dann auch Leute sozusagen in Situationen gegen das Gesetz stellt,
wo es aber real kein, also unterstelle ich jetzt mal, ich habe jetzt nicht alle
Situationen gesehen und mit Sicherheit schreibt er auch mal Leute auf,
wo man sagt, das geht ja gar nicht. Gar keine Frage.
Aber es gibt sicherlich eine Menge Situationen, wo man sagt,
hast du sie noch alle? Ja, das ist das Problem.
Ganz ordentlich alle. Also das ist ja auch klar, aber man muss doch auch mal
so einen Typ mal embracen und sagen, Mann ey, so groß ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass ich die Freude habe mit dem nicht.
Und jetzt, ja, jetzt darf ich nicht mehr im Halteverbot parken.
Meine Güte. Also ich weiß nicht, wie oft die, wann immer ich ein Auto hatte
in Berlin, weißt du, wie oft die mir die Dinger abgeschleppt hatten?
Weil, was da nämlich passiert ist, Auto in Berlin kann ja keine Sorge brauchen,
also steht das die ganze Zeit rum.
Also kommt irgendwann einer und stellt da ein Halteverbotsschild hin und dann
kommt der Abschlepp-LKW und dann kriegst du eine Rechnung für weiß ich nicht,
150 Euro kostet das Abschleppen, 70 Euro,
das Parken im Halteverbot und so weiter,
Das ist Teil des Sports.
Man muss einfach kontextsensitiv vorgehen.
Sagen wir mal so, ich hätte keinerlei der Handzeigenhauptmeister verliert meine
persönliche schützende Hand, sobald der irgendwie einen Radfahrer belästigt.
Sogar die Polizei kann ganz entspannt sein.
Also ich hab's irgendwie tatsächlich mal gebracht, dass ich irgendwie so zerstört und völlig,
ermüdet von irgendeiner Veranstaltung zurückkam, uns wirklich gebracht habe,
das Auto, mit dem ich fuhr, auf der Straße stehen zu lassen.
Der Schlüssel war noch drin und ich bin wie oben in die Wohnung reingegangen
und bin oben eingeschlafen.
Da kannst du aber froh sein, dass die dich erst erwischt haben,
nachdem du den Rausch ausgeschlafen hattest.
Nee, ich war gar nicht so betraut. Das war kein Alkoholismus.
Ich war wirklich nur vollkommen, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau,
was der Grund war, aber ich war einfach todmüde und bin einfach eingeschlafen.
Und ja, das konnte aber auch noch alles sehr entspannt und ohne größere Strafen
geregelt werden. Die haben sich einfach nur sehr gewundert.
Was wollen wir denn jetzt eigentlich mit dieser Meldung jetzt sagen,
aber die würden es jetzt so ausführlich geäußert haben Du möchtest gerne.
Dass er nicht.
Getötet wird jetzt.
Also ich finde dürfen eins nicht vergessen die Leute, die ihn angegriffen haben
das hätte ich vielleicht noch früher dazu sagen sollen die haben den in der
Bahn erkannt das waren keine Opfer von dem,
Leute.
Haben ihn angegriffen? Ja. Hast du das schon erwähnt?
Der hat, also der wurde angegriffen. Der ist Opfer einer Körperverletzung geworden. Und zwar,
Nicht, wie es zu erwarten gestanden hätte,
dass der früher oder später halt einen auf die Fresse kriegt von jemandem,
dem er im falschen Moment einen reinwürgt,
sondern offenbar ist das am Abend des 2.
März nach einem Match von Dynamo Dresden beim Halleschen FC.
Und sagen wir mal so, Dynamo Dresden-Fans stelle ich mir nicht so angenehm vor.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das Spiel verlaufen ist.
Heimfans, dann war es in Halle. 18.20 Uhr, als die Bahn von etwa 20 Heimfans
nach dem Spiel genutzt wurde, der Jugendliche wurde anschließend verletzt in
ein Krankenhaus gebracht.
Sein Mobiltelefon wurde später auf dem Bahnsteig gefunden. gefunden.
So, das heißt, er hat jetzt von Menschen, die er, mit denen er nichts zu Leide
getan hat, angegriffen.
Und das ist, denke ich, eine eindeutige direkte Konsequenz dieser Spiegel Online-Doku
und der massenhaften Aufmerksamkeit, die der natürlich überall bekommen hat.
Heißt das jetzt, dass man ich meine jetzt mal die Perspektive Spiegel-TV Spiegel,
was war das? Spiegel-Online? Spiegel-TV?
Spiegel, es gibt ja keine also Spiegel-TV ist sowieso nochmal was anderes als
Spiegel-Online, aber inzwischen gibt es ja gar keine Unterscheidung mehr.
Okay, also dieses Fernsehteam, was halt schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren dieses
Spiegel-TV macht, das ist ja jetzt beileibe nicht das erste Produkt dieser Art.
Denkst du, dass dass das jetzt, sagen wir mal, die Ursünde in diesem Fall ist,
dass man darüber berichtet?
Also ich meine, wenn du jetzt so ein Journalist wärst.
Ich bedauere, ich muss einfach mal wirklich mein Bedauern darüber ausdrücken,
dass dem Internet die Reife fehlt, um sich an sowas zu erfreuen.
Und dass wir eine Situation haben, wo so einer, Und das war ja,
also, es haben ja wirklich viele vorhergesagt, dass der, und da brauchst du auch nicht viel, ähm.
Kompetenz zu, um dir vorzustellen, dass der eine sehr fürchterliche,
dass diese Öffentlichkeit, die er jetzt bekommt, für ihn fürchterliche Folgen haben wird.
Das hat auch ein Artikel im RND auch schon vorhergesagt.
Der sagte so, das ist schlimm, der wird Opfer von Gewalt werden.
Drachendort gelodet sozusagen.
Ja, und das finde ich halt fair game, wenn das in der Situation ist,
wo er jemandem auf den Sack geht, wenn das jetzt irgendwie eines seiner konkreten
Opfer ist, dass er sich nicht anders zu helfen weiß, weil er sich nicht artikulieren kann, ist okay.
Ich denke, das ist ein Risiko, was er selber kennt.
Und vielleicht notfalls mit seinem Pulli-2-Fahrrad dann da wegfährt oder so.
Dass der jetzt quasi eine Zielperson öffentlicher Hetze ist, finde ich halt schlimm.
Ja, ist auch schlimm. Ja.
Aber er macht das noch. Bis man nicht...
Ich würde ihm einfach raten, such dir ein anderes Hobby. Es gibt andere schöne
Dinge, die man machen kann.
Also wenn man so einen Spaß dran hat, Gesetze umzusetzen, da gibt es auch sogar
ein Berufsbild dazu. Wie heißt das nochmal gleich?
Polifzai?
Polifzi. Nee, Rechtspfleger heißt das.
Rechtspfleger. Da könnt ihr doch Rechtspflege machen. Das wird doch vielleicht was für ihn. Naja.
Aber also.
Alle Beteiligten haben ja eigentlich irgendwie so ein bisschen mal drüber nachzudenken,
was sie eigentlich tun, würde ich sagen. Ja genau.
Welche Veränderung möchtest du in der Welt machen?
Also die Journalisten sollten sich ein bisschen darüber Gedanken machen,
was ihre Berichterstattung für Auswirkungen hat.
Die Hater sollen einfach mal kacken gehen und Herr Hauptmeister selber.
Herr Nanter, sollte sich auch mal überlegen. Und die Polizei,
die müssen ihr Nummernschild sauber machen.
Ich meine, man könnte ja auch Briefmarken sammeln oder Blumen pressen oder es
gibt so viele schöne Hobbys, mit denen man seine Zeit sinnlos vergeuden kann. Warum das?
Naja, okay.
Jetzt machen wir hier Schluss.
Internet pflege deine Helden, sonst hast du halt irgendwann keine mehr.
Haben wir sonst noch was beizutragen? Nee, ne? Nee, ist auch schon wieder ganz
schön lang hier unsere Sendung, glaube ich, oder?
Ich schau mal Uiuiui, ja das reicht,
Gut Leute damit schicken wir euch in die Woche und,
mir fällt mir jetzt irgendwie nicht dazu ein Nee.
Mir auch nicht Ja.
Auch nicht.
Achso, du musst ja jetzt...
Nee, nee, muss ich nicht.
Okay. Ciao, ciao.